I'm Jennifer Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scene stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies.
我是詹妮弗·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作终极的《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有亲历者才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室娇娃。
Hello! Hey there! Today's episode is Andy's ancestry. What are we going to find out? We're going to find out a lot. It's season 9, episode 3. This episode was written by Jonathan Green and gave Miller. This is a new writer alert. New writers. Yes, new writing team alert. They were a new writing team for this season.
大家好！嘿！今天的剧集是《安迪的祖先》。我们会发现什么呢？我们会发现很多东西。这是第九季第三集。这一集由乔纳森·格林和盖布·米勒编剧。这是一则新编剧警报。新编剧。是的，新编剧团队警报。他们是本季的新编剧团队。
Before joining the office, they had written on the class and late show with David Letterman. And after the office, they worked on the Cleveland show, the Mindy Project, Superstore and American Auto. And they were really nice guys. They were. This episode was directed by Dave Rogers. Would you like a summary? I really would because then I have some call sheet information for you. Oh, I'm loving you in these call sheets. You didn't read them when we were on the show. No, I literally do it. I stepped over them. They would put them by our doors. They would slide them under and I would be like, why do these papers? I love a call sheet.
在加入《办公室》之前，他们曾在《中间人》和《大卫·莱特曼深夜秀》担任编剧。在《办公室》之后，他们参与了《克利夫兰秀》、《明迪烦事多》、《超级店员》和《美式汽车》的制作。他们真的是很好的人。确实是的。这一集由戴夫·罗杰斯执导。你想要剧情概要吗？我非常需要，因为接下来我有一些通告单信息要分享。噢，我太喜欢你关注这些通告单了。我们在剧组时你可没读过它们。不，我真的会读。我会从它们上面跨过去。他们会把通告单放在我们的门边。他们会把通告单从门缝底下塞进来，而我会想，为什么要有这些纸？我太喜欢通告单了。
I know. I would read them front and back. I would. I would study them. I'm so excited you're into the call sheets, Aege. 20 years later. Don't ever give up on yourself, people. You have it in you to discover new things about yourself.
我知道。我会正反两面都仔细阅读。我会的。我会研究它们。安吉，很高兴你对通告单这么感兴趣。20年后的今天。永远不要放弃自我，各位。你们体内都有发掘自我新一面的潜能。
Here is your summary for this episode. Nelly retaliates against Andy's bullying by falsifying his family tree. Aaron learns a new language in order to impress Andy and his family. Pam helps Nelly practice driving for her upcoming driving test, and Darryl helps Jim come clean with the secret that he's been keeping from Pam. That summary is rich. Yeah. Angela, I have fast facts but do you need to hit us with your call sheet delights first? I would like to just set the temperature for the week for everybody. Are you gonna continue to tell us the weather? Am I so old? I'm like, how your parents just have the weather channel on all the time?
以下是本剧集的剧情梗概：奈莉伪造了安迪的家谱，以此来回击安迪对她的霸凌。艾琳为了给安迪及其家人留下好印象而学习了一门新语言。帕姆帮助奈莉为即将到来的驾考练习开车，达里尔则帮吉姆向帕姆坦白他一直瞒着的秘密。这个剧情梗概内容很丰富。是的。安吉，我这里有快速事实，但你需要先用你的通告单趣事震撼我们吗？我想先为每个人设定一下这周的温度。你打算继续给我们播报天气吗？我是不是太老气了？我感觉自己就像那些整天开着天气频道看个不停的父母一样？
A little bit. A little bit. Okay. Well, Steve Burgess, you know, you're my favorite fella who loves to take sunset photos by the lake. He gave me all the call sheets for season nine. I have all of them, lady. It's very exciting. I need everyone to know that the first day of filming happened on August 13th, 2012, the high was 97 degrees. Still real hot. Day two, high of 100. It continued into the high 90s for the rest of the week. The one other thing I want to share with you guys, I'm going to put this in stories as
有点像。有点像。好吧，史蒂夫·伯吉斯，你知道的，你是我最喜欢的、喜欢在湖边拍日落照片的那个老兄。他给了我第九季所有的通告单。我有所有的通告单，女士。这太令人兴奋了。我需要让每个人都知道，第一天拍摄是在2012年8月13日，最高气温是97华氏度。依然非常热。第二天，最高气温100华氏度。接下来的整个星期气温都持续在90华氏度的高位。我还有一件事想和大家分享，我会把这个发在动态里，
well. These call sheets for Andy's ancestry were so heavy with special announcements for all of the meetings they had to take for work bus the next week. Yes, while we were shooting this, they were prepping that. In fact, they just started putting buses on all the call sheets, like little images of buses. That's very cute. So I'll share that in stories, but yeah, and then I will have
也就是这个。关于《安迪的祖先》的通告单里塞满了关于下周工作巴士会议的特别公告。是的，我们在拍这一场时，他们正在筹备那个。事实上，他们刚刚开始把巴士印在所有的通告单上，就像是巴士的小图标。这非常可爱。所以我会在动态里分享这个，但是是的，接下来我还有
a few get to know your cast and crew moments coming up. I love it. Well, fast fact number one, Angela, is that we had a very special guest star on this episode Randall Park. Yes, is in our cold open. You might recognize Randall from Fresh Off the Boat or Juan Division. You know, the New Yorker did a fantastic profile on him last year. It's definitely worth a read. So last year Randall Park directed a film
一些“了解你的演员和剧组”的时刻。我太喜欢了。好吧，快速事实一，安吉拉，我们在这一集里有一个非常特别的客串明星——兰道尔·朴。是的，他出现在我们的片头。你可能会从《初来乍到》或《旺达幻视》中认出兰道尔。你知道的，《纽约客》去年为他写了一篇精彩的人物专访。绝对值得一读。所以去年兰道尔·朴执导了一部电影
called Short Cummings. It's based on the graphic novel by Adrian Tomina. Okay, you know that I went through a nerd out time in my life where I was super endographic novels. I love Adrian Tomina so much. So this whole New Yorker profile was kind of around the subject. So anyway, give it a read. It's very, very good. I'll find it and put it in stories. Yes. Yes. So Randall also did an interview for NPR where he said that despite the popularity of fresh off the boat and Juan Division and being part of that world, the two
叫做《短评》。它改编自阿德里安·托米纳的图画小说。好吧，你知道我经历过一段极客时期，当时我超级痴迷图画小说。我非常喜欢阿德里安·托米纳。所以这篇《纽约客》的专访差不多就是围绕这个主题展开的。总之，去读读看吧。非常非常棒。我会找到它并发布在动态里。是的。是的。所以兰道尔还接受了NPR的采访，在采访中他说，尽管《初来乍到》和《旺达幻视》很受欢迎，他也成为了那个世界的一部分，但他最常被认出来的两件事情
things that he gets recognized for the most are for playing Kim Jong-un in the movie The Interview and for the office. Really? Yes, those two things. Those are the things people yell out to him on the street. But he said, for a period of time, he actually forgot that he had been on the office. Well, yeah, because he's gone on to do so many things. Yes. And that people shout out to him on the street and he was confused. He actually told the story to Conan O'Brien and I have an audio clip.
其实是在电影《采访》中扮演金正恩以及出演《办公室》。真的吗？是的，就是这两件事。人们在街上对大喊的就是这些。但他说，有一段时间，他甚至忘记自己曾出演过《办公室》。好吧，是的，因为他后来做了太多事情。是的。人们在街上对他大喊大叫，他还感到很困惑。他实际上把这个故事讲给了柯南·奥布莱恩听，我有一段音频剪辑。
Great. You did a role on the office, and when I heard about this, I thought, oh, okay, well, maybe you had an arc on the office. It wasn't an arc. No, no. You were barely in the office. And they found that character. Tell us about that. I mean, I did. So this was like many years ago, it was the final season of the office. I got the chance to play a character named Asian Jim in like one scene during the final season. And at that point, the popularity of the show had been waning. And I was in and out in an hour and I thought that was really fun. And then I just kind of completely forgot about it.
太好了。你在《办公室》里客串了一个角色，当我听到这个消息时，我想，哦，好吧，也许你在《办公室》里有一条故事线。这算不上故事线。不，不。你在办公室里几乎没怎么出场。他们找到了那个角色。跟我们讲讲吧。我的确演了。所以那是好几年前的事了，那是《办公室》的最终季。我有机会在最终季的一场戏中扮演一个名叫“亚裔吉姆”的角色。当时，这部剧的热度正在减退。我进去呆了一个小时就出来了，我觉得这真的很有趣。然后我就把这事完全忘光了。
And then several years later, I'm like walking down the street and this car drives by and a guy else like, Asian Jim and drives off. And I'm thinking like, is this some like racist thing that I don't know about? Either you either a fan just saw you or it's a hate crime. I thought it was a hate crime, you know, because I had forgotten about my appearance on the office. And, you know, people would be walking up to me, like, what's up, Asian Jim?
然后好几年后，我在街上走着，一辆车开过去，有个家伙大喊：“亚裔吉姆！”然后开车走了。当时我在想，这是什么我不知道的种族歧视梗吗？要么是有粉丝刚好看到你，要么就是仇恨犯罪。我以为这是一场仇恨犯罪，你知道的，因为我早就忘了我客串过《办公室》。而且，你知道的，人们会走到我面前说，最近怎么样啊，亚裔吉姆？
I'd be like, fuck you. That's all. What do you, you know? And then, by the way, I want to apologize for greeting you when you came here to the studio. And you went like that. Yeah, I did that. And whatever. I mean, man, I was way out of bounds. Isn't that crazy? Yeah. Have you ever done something that you forgot? And then you were reminded later, are there roles like that? Oh, yeah, for sure.
我会说：去你的。就这样。你觉得呢？然后，顺便说一句，当您来到这个工作室时，我想为我迎接您的方式向您道歉。然后你做出了那种表情。对，我做了那个。随便吧。我的意思是，老兄，我当时真是太出格了。这不是很疯狂吗？是的。你有没有做过某件事然后把它给忘了？后来又被提醒想起来？有没有这样的角色？哦，当然有，肯定的。
I was actually doing a Q&A at a university. There's a bunch of college kids. They were so wonderful. Everyone had questions about the office. And then this one guy raised his hand and said, I don't have a question, just my favorite quote. So I thought it was gonna be from the office.
我当时其实正在一所大学做问答环节。现场有一群大学生。他们太棒了。每个人都有关于《办公室》的问题。然后有一个家伙举手说，我没有问题，只想分享我最喜欢的台词。所以我以为那会出自《办公室》。
And he quoted my character from Hotwives of Orlando. And I was clearly confused at first. I was like, what? And then he was like, how was it confused at first. I was like, what? And then he was like, how was it for Lando? I was like, oh, yes, right. Yes, I did that. Well, we had a fan question from Claudia L. in Miami, Florida who said, please tell us
结果他引用了我《奥兰多娇妻》里的角色台词。我一开始明显很困惑。我在想，什么？然后他说，奥兰多那部剧怎么样？我说，哦，是的，没毛病。是的，我演过那个。好了，我们收到了来自佛罗里达州迈阿密的粉丝克劳迪娅·L.的问题，她说，请告诉我们
how it was working with Randall Park. You know what? Claudia, it's what he said. We allotted one hour for that cold open. He was in and out. I barely met him before I smooched him. He was so nice, but it was just like a very kind of like professional moment. Really, it's so funny.
和兰道尔·朴合作是什么感觉。你知道吗？克劳迪娅，就像他说的。我们为那个片头预留了一个小时。他来了就走了。我在亲吻他之前几乎都没怎么见过他。他人非常好，但这只是一种非常职业的时刻。真的，太搞笑了。
And we shot those cold opens really quickly. We did. And this cold open has become one of the most famous, most popular. But for us, it was like one hour of our work day. We had no idea that it would take off the way it did. Or that Randall Park would take off the way he did. But I liked him. He was lovely and funny and ready to go.
而且我们拍那些片头拍得非常快。确实如此。而这个片头已经成为了最著名、最受欢迎的片头之一。但对我们来说，它就像是我们工作日里的一小时。我们根本不知道它会以那种方式走红。也不知道兰道尔·朴会以那样的方式走红。但我很喜欢他。他非常可爱、有趣，随时准备开拍。
You know, all the best things. I'm so thankful I got to work with Randall again because I played Amy Chestnut in Fresh Off the Boat. Yes. And we had a few episodes together. I'm so thankful I got to work with Randall again because I played Amy Chestnut and fresh off the boat. Yes! And we had a few episodes together. We had some great scenes where we were on a double date. And we were laughing so hard and they let us improvise a little and he is so fun. And I really enjoyed my time on that show and really enjoyed working with him. Are you ready for FastFact number two?
你知道的，所有最美好的事情。我很感激能有机会再次与兰道尔合作，因为我在《初来乍到》中扮演了埃米·切斯特纳特。是的。我们一起拍了好几集。我很感激能有机会再次与兰道尔合作，因为我在《初来乍到》中扮演了埃米·切斯特纳特。是的！我们一起拍了好几集。我们有一些非常棒的戏份，是一场双重约会。我们笑得太厉害了，他们允许我们即兴发挥了一点，他真的太有趣了。我非常享受在那部剧里的时光，也非常享受和他的合作。你准备好听第二个快速事实了吗？
I am. All right, this is a fan question from Selena P in Chandler, Arizona, who has a question about our season nine set. Okay. Selena said whose decision was it to change the lighting of the office? Season nine is so much brighter than the rest of the series
我准备好了。好的，这是一个来自亚利桑那州钱德勒的粉丝塞莱娜·P.的问题，她有一个关于我们第九季片场的问题。好吧。塞莱娜说，是谁决定改变办公室的灯光的？第九季比本剧的其他部分要亮得多，
and I've always wondered why. What a good catch. Well, Selena, I reached out to Greg Daniels and he said the Dave Rogers, our editor, and subsequently the director of this episode, had been complaining for a couple of years that the lighting seemed to be getting darker and darker. Really? Yes, and so they had a big meeting about it, and they actually felt that the lighting this season was more of a restoration of our original look. And so, good eye! They did bump up the lighting, Selena.
我一直很好奇为什么。真是个敏锐的发现。好吧，塞莱娜，我联系了格雷格·丹尼尔斯，他说我们的剪辑师、随后也是本剧导演的戴夫·罗杰斯，已经抱怨了好几年，说灯光似乎越来越暗了。真的吗？是的，所以他们为此开了一场大会，他们其实觉得这一季的灯光更像是对我们最初外观的还原。所以，眼光真好！他们确实调亮了灯光，塞莱娜。
I'm so impressed that you recognized this. I kind of want to do a side-by-side. Maybe we should. Yeah. I'll also tell you, Selena, that after I had my baby, I got a bunch of melasma on my face, you know, the dark spots. And they were having a really hard time because the lighting in our office wasn't traditional kind of movie lighting where they light the actors from the front.
我太佩服你能注意到这一点了。我甚至有点想做一个对比。也许我们应该这样做。是的。我还要告诉你，塞莱娜，在我生完孩子后，我的脸长了很多黄褐斑，你知道的，就是那些黑斑。他们当时遇到了很大的困难，因为我们办公室的灯光不是那种传统的电影灯光，那种灯光会从正面照亮演员。
It's not the pretty lighting. It's the overhead lighting. Everyone looks like they're a crypt keeper or something. And it was actually that overhead lighting was enhancing these melasma spots on my face and the makeup department literally couldn't put more makeup on my face. If you notice that Pam's makeup is a little heavier in season 9, it's because of this melasma. And actually bumping up the lighting helped with that.
那不是好看的灯光。那是头顶上方的顶光。每个人看起来都像是个掘墓人或者别的什么。事实上，正是这种顶光加重了我脸上的黄褐斑，化妆部门简直无法在我的脸上涂更多的粉底了。如果你注意到帕姆在第九季的妆容稍微厚了一点，这就是因为这些黄褐斑。事实上，调亮灯光对解决这个问题有所帮助。
I had to do a bunch of test lighting days. They would combine certain makeup with certain lighting and they ended up creating a little tiny like portable light box that would sit on my desk and shine on my face from below to help counteract the shadows from our overhead lighting system. And then the makeup department tried a bunch of things. But yeah, there was a bunch of new lighting stuff happening in season nine. Yeah, I mean, I know we don't want to go off
我不得不做了一堆灯光测试日。他们会将特定的妆容与特定的灯光结合起来，最后他们创造了一个小小的便携式灯箱，可以放在我的桌子上，从下方照亮我的脸，以帮助抵消头顶照明系统带来的阴影。然后化妆部门尝试了很多方法。但是是的，第九季确实出现了很多新的灯光调整。是的，我的意思是，我知道我们不想跑题，
on this tangent, but just the things women's bodies go through to have a baby. Yeah, the spots on the face that have never gone away for me. They've lightened now over the years, but then I had another baby and then hello again. That's it. And then where's my little box lip? Yeah, I, at that point I was like,
但仅仅是为了生个孩子，女人的身体就要经历这么多。是的，脸上的斑点对我来说就再也没有消失过。这些年颜色变浅了，但后来我又生了一个孩子，然后，嗨，又见面了。就是这样。然后，我的小灯箱在哪儿呢？对，我当时就想，
I travel with a box lip. I wish. All right, fast fact number three. I'll have you know this episode was very well received by critics. The new critic over at the AV Club, Eric Adams gave it a B. I did not see any comments from miles. I looked through all the comments. Okay.
我是带着灯箱旅行的。但愿吧。好吧，第三个快速事实。我要告诉你们，这一集受到了评论界的好评。AV俱乐部的新评论员埃里克·亚当斯给它打了B。我没有看到迈尔斯的任何评论。我把所有的评论都翻了一遍。好吧。
Nothing yet. What about a Steve B? Didn't see a Steve B. Okay. Mark Trammell of TV equals named it quote, the best episode of the final season of the office to date. Well, I thought that was nice, but Mark, it's only the third one. It's a big proclamation. It is.
还不知道。史蒂夫·B怎么样？没看到史蒂夫·B。好吧。电视等于频道的马克·特拉梅尔将其评为，《办公室》最后一季迄今为止最佳单集。嗯，我觉得这挺好，但马克，这才是第三集。这个评价太高了。确实如此。
And after this episode aired, Eonline said that Pete, aka Jake Lacey was quote, especially charming, and named him one of the best things in pop culture this week. Let me tell you, people had their eye on Jake. Yep, he was going to be a superstar. I got curious about what other things were on the best things in pop culture this week, along with Jake.
在这集播出后，E! Online网站表示，皮特，也就是杰克·莱西，堪称“格外迷人”，并将其评为本周流行文化中最棒的事物之一。说实话，大家都盯着杰克呢。没错，他要成为超级巨星了。我很好奇，除了杰克之外，本周流行文化中还有哪些其他最棒的事物。
You want to hear some of them? Sure. You know I love a list. Okay. Well, there was a NASA Laddy spacecraft lift off and during the lift off, a frog jumped up in frame. So there's a frog photo bombed the lift off. Do you want to
你想听听其中一些吗？当然想。你知道我最喜欢列清单了。好吧。嗯，当时有一个美国宇航局的拉迪太空探测器发射升空，在发射过程中，一只青蛙跳进了画面里。所以这是一只青蛙给发射过程来了个“抢镜”。你想
see a picture? Yes. So NASA has a spaceship. What do you call them? I don't know. NASA has a thing going out into space. Yeah. And a frog eclipse the moment. Yeah, because they take a picture, sure of the tailbrow.
看照片吗？想看。所以美国宇航局有个宇宙飞船。你们管它叫什么？我不知道。美国宇航局有个东西要飞向太空。是的。然后一只青蛙抢了风头。是的，因为他们拍了照片，当然是拍尾部的……
Yeah, lift off. Uh-huh. And this frog jumped up like a photo bomb. And it went viral and it became, here you'll see it. You see the little frog? Oh my god. I now remember this. Oh buddy.
对，发射升空。嗯哼。然后这只青蛙就像抢镜一样跳了起来。然后它就火了，变成了……这里你能看到。看到那只小青蛙了吗？哦天哪。我这会儿记起来了。噢，老兄。
Well, listen, I am sorry. This frog is not jumping. What's it doing? This frog is being catapulted by the force of the liftoff. Please look at this and tell me you think he's jumping. He's like, he does. He does look a little catapulted. I'll give you this photo. You can put it in storage, Angela. Another thing that was one of the best things in pop culture this week were Freddie Prince, Jr.'s abs, portraits of babies eating lemons.
好吧，听着，我很抱歉。这只青蛙根本没在跳。它在干嘛？这只青蛙是被发射升空的冲击力给弹射出去的。请看看这个，然后告诉我你觉得它是在跳。它看起来……它确实看起来有点像被弹射出去的。这张照片送给你。你可以把它存起来，安吉拉。本周流行文化中另外一件最棒的事物是小小弗雷迪·普林斯的腹肌，以及宝宝们吃柠檬的照片。
You'll like this one. Tiny hats on cats. Love a tiny hat. Love it. Just any animal. Any animal. Any animal. Yes. The despicable me sound track. Oh, Harry Styles is dog. Oh, and the mega burger pizza. What? So they take multiple burger patties and then they sandwich them between two large pizzas and then they topped the pizza with burger toppings. It was being sold in Kyoto. It weighed three pounds and costs 26 dollars, the mega burger pizza. We should also note Kevin would have eaten this. Yeah, he would have invented it.
你会喜欢这个的。猫咪戴小帽子。超爱小帽子。太喜欢了。任何动物都行。任何动物。任何动物。是的。《神偷奶爸》原声带。哦，哈里·斯泰尔斯的狗。哦，还有巨无霸汉堡披萨。什么？所以他们把好几个汉堡肉饼叠在一起，然后夹在两个大披萨中间，还在披萨上面铺满了汉堡的配料。这当时在京都出售。它重达三磅，售价26美元，就是这个巨无霸汉堡披萨。我们还应该指出，凯文一定会吃这个。对，他绝对会发明这东西的。
He would have invented it. Look at his dip. Yeah. His super bowl dip. Mm-hmm. This is his kind of pizza. Well, there you have it. I kind of want to look up the best things in pop culture every week now, because it was really fun. Yes! Do it. Okay. I have a list coming up that you are going to love. As someone who I've taken a road trip with, I can't wait to share it with you. Oh, I'm very excited. Well, why don't we take a break? And then we will start breaking down this very famous cold open. We are back. Dwight is at his desk and a new guy enters and sits at Jim's desk. He's
他肯定会发明这东西的。看看他的蘸酱。没错。他的超级碗蘸酱。嗯哼。这就是他的那种披萨。好了，事情就是这样。我现在有点想去查查每周流行文化中最棒的事物是什么了，因为真的很有趣。没错！去查吧。好吧。我接下来要念一个清单，你一定会喜欢的。作为曾经和我一起公路旅行的人，我迫不及待想跟你分享。哦，我太兴奋了。要不我们休息一下？然后我们就开始剖析这个非常著名的开场短剧。我们回来啦。德怀特坐在办公桌前，一个新来的家伙走进来，坐在了吉姆的座位上。他
claiming to be Jim. He even has Jim's water bottle says Jim and Sharpie. He knows Jim's voicemail code. Yeah. Dwight is trying to stump this guy with questions. He's unsuccessful. And then Pam walks out, gives him a kiss, and then there are family photos. He's in all the family photos. Yeah, Pam has the talking head. She says Jim is at the dentist. Steve is an actor, friend of ours. This is a prank on Dwight.
自称是吉姆。他甚至拿着吉姆的水壶，上面用马克笔写着“吉姆”。他知道吉姆的语音信箱密码。对。德怀特试图用问题难倒这家伙。他没有成功。然后帕姆走出来，给了他一个吻，接着还有全家福。他出现在所有的全家福里。对，帕姆有单采镜头。她说吉姆去看牙医了。史蒂夫是个演员，也是我们的朋友。这是对德怀特的恶作剧。
Can I just say that Pam has really signed up for this prank? I mean, she's all in on this prank. She like kisses their friend Steve. Did you see my hair, dude? Yeah. It's a little judged. I kissed Steve on the lips? Yeah. Not on the cheek.
我能说帕姆真的全力配合了这个恶作剧吗？我是说，她完全投入到这个恶作剧里了。她竟然去亲了他们的朋友史蒂夫。你看见我的发型了吗，老兄？对。有点精心打理过。我亲了史蒂夫的嘴唇？没错。不是亲脸颊。
Not hey babe on the cheek. When's the last time Pam kissed Jim on the lips? Well. It's been a while. Well, Pam's like I'm all in. Yeah. We actually got a piece of fan mail from Sue in China who said why would Pam kiss a random friend like that?
不是那种打招呼式的亲脸颊。帕姆上一次亲吉姆的嘴唇是什么时候？这个嘛。已经过去好久了。好吧，帕姆的态度就是我奉陪到底。没错。我们实际上收到了一封来自中国苏州的粉丝来信，上面写着为什么帕姆会去亲一个普通朋友呢？
And why did the rest of the office seem so unbothered? And Kiara from Belgium said would Jim be okay with his friend Steve kissing his wife as part of a prank? I guess they were. I have a theory. Oh, please tell me. Mm-hmm. Well, who needs to sneak off all the time now?
为什么办公室里的其他人看起来都无动于衷？还有来自比利时的基亚拉说，作为恶作剧的一部分，吉姆会介意他的朋友史蒂夫亲吻他的妻子吗？我想他们是不介意的。我有个理论。哦，快告诉我。嗯哼。好吧，现在谁需要经常偷偷溜出去呢？
Jim. Mm-hmm. Who figured out a prank where he didn't have to be at work? Jim. Mm-hmm. Pam's gonna get hers, I guess. I don't know. I will say it was slightly awkward, as it always is, on acting days like this, where you meet someone and you shake hands and say, oh, hi, I'm Jenna, hi, I'm Randall, it was slightly awkward as it always is on acting days like this, where you meet someone and you shake hands and say, oh, hi, I'm Jenna, hi, I'm Randall, and then now we're smooching. Yeah.
吉姆。嗯哼。是谁想出了一个不用去上班就能搞恶作剧的办法？吉姆。嗯哼。我想帕姆也会得到她想要的吧。我不知道。我得说，这稍微有点尴尬，就像这种表演日一样，总是会这样，你遇到某个人，然后握手说，哦，嗨，我是珍娜，嗨，我是兰德尔，这稍微有点尴尬，就像这种表演日一样，总是会这样，你遇到某个人，然后握手说，哦，嗨，我是珍娜，嗨，我是兰德尔，然后现在我们要亲热了。没错。
Like, here we go. Yeah. So like I said before, this cold open always makes the best lists and a screen rant compiled a list of the 10 best office cold opens. This is based on Reddit debates. This one is on it. I wondered if you could guess the rest.
就像，开始吧。没错。所以正如我之前所说，这个开场短剧总是能进入最佳排行榜，Screen Rant网站整理了一份《办公室》10大最佳开场短剧排行榜。这是基于红迪网（Reddit）上的辩论得出的。这个短剧就榜上有名。我在想你能否猜出剩下的.
I don't know, but I love a Reddit debate. I know. We don't even understand how Reddit works, but we like how to sign up. I don't know how. I find it half the time. I don't understand the threads, but when I do find something there, it's always delicious.
我不知道，但我超爱红迪网上的辩论。我知道。我们甚至都搞不懂红迪网是怎么运作的，但我们喜欢怎么注册。我不知道怎么弄。我有一半时间都找不到。我看不懂那些讨论串，但每当我在上面找到点什么，总是津津有味。
I know. I don't get it. I don't get it. It's the mystery for us. Do you need like to sign up? Do you need a sign in? I don't know. I don't, maybe if you want to start a contributor. Yeah. Is that what you're called? I don't even know. I don't know. A poster? No. Posting it. I don't know. Post it. All right. I don't ever want us to figure out Reddit. I just want you to know that.
我懂。我不懂。我不懂。这对我们来说是个谜。你需要注册吗？你需要登录吗？我不知道。我……也许如果你想成为贡献者的话。对。那是这么叫的吗？我甚至都不知道。我不知道。发帖人？不对。发帖。好吧。我永远都不想让我们去搞懂红迪网。我只想让你知道这一点。
Like, if there's anyone right now writing in like ladies, this is how you do Reddit. I don't ever want to learn it. I just like it that it's this mystery place where there's fun tidbits. Yeah. Mystery online place. I agree.
比如，如果现在有人写信说，女士们，这才是玩红迪网的正确方式。我永远都不想去学它。我只是喜欢它作为一个充满有趣小花絮的神秘地方。没错。神秘的网络地方。我同意。
All right. Are you gonna guess the other top called events? Oh, okay. I will guess that. I will try to. Try to guess. Fire drill. Yes.
好了。你要猜其他顶级的开场短剧吗？哦，好吧。我来猜。我会试一试的。试着猜。消防演习。是的。
Oh gosh, let's see. What about when Jim wrapped Dwight's whole desk in a wrapping paper? Yes. That was number two. Okay. Have I hit number one? No.
哦天哪，让我想想。吉姆用包装纸把德怀特的整个办公桌都包起来那次怎么样？对。那是第二名。好吧。我猜中第一名了吗？没有。
You're just not thinking of it. It's like whole cookbooks have been written. Oh, Kevin's chilly. Yes. Okay. Kevin's chilly. I'll tell you the rest. The exercise ball. Oh, yeah. Parkour. Parkour. The murder scene that Jim sets up in the hotel room during Tallahassee. Oh my gosh. Future Dwight. Future Dwight was great. Identity theft, bear's beats, battle star galactic theft. I liked that one. And the Pavlov prank, which I didn't totally remember.
你只是没往那想。就好像整本食谱都被写出来了。哦，凯文的辣酱。没错。好吧。凯文的辣酱。我来告诉你剩下的。平衡球。哦，对。跑酷。跑酷。吉姆在塔拉哈西的酒店房间里布置的谋杀现场。哦天哪。未来的德怀特。未来的德怀特太棒了。身份盗用，熊、碳基生命、太空堡垒卡拉狄加盗窃案。我喜欢那个。还有巴甫洛夫恶作剧，这个我记不太清了。
It's from season three. Oh, it's when the bell brings the bell. And that is that when he slowly makes his handset heavier by putting the coins because I loved that. I thought it was. And then he picks up the phone and he hits himself in the head when he takes the comb. Yeah, I love that one. Anyway, there you go We did get a fan mail flurry about this cold open people wondering about the kiss
那是第三季里的。哦，就是那个按铃的铃。那是当他通过放硬币慢慢让他的话筒变重的时候吗？因为我太喜欢那个了。我觉得那太……然后他拿起电话，当他拿走话筒时，他自己砸到了头上。对，我喜欢那个。不管怎样，就是这样。我们确实收到了一大堆关于这个开场短剧的粉丝来信，人们都在好奇那个吻的事。
But we also got this question from Glysset in Houston, Texas Angela, yes, Glysset Why are you standing near your desk in the background looking at what's going on during the cold open with what I would describe as a quote happy curiosity? I feel like Angela would normally be annoyed by these types of shenanigans. Okay, I love this question. I went back and watched the scene very carefully and I called Busted on myself. Oscar was showing me something on his computer and I am tickled by it.
但我们还收到了来自德克萨斯州休斯顿的格利瑟特的提问：安吉拉，是的，格利瑟特。为什么在开场短剧期间，你站在背景里的办公桌旁，用我所形容的“快乐的好奇心”看着正在发生的事情？我觉得安吉拉平时会对这种恶作剧感到厌烦才对。好吧，我很喜欢这个问题。我回去非常仔细地看了一遍那个场景，然后我抓到自己的“现行”了。奥斯卡当时在电脑上给我看什么东西，我觉得很有意思。
One point, I don't even try to hide. I'm literally leaning over his shoulder and more watching something. Yeah. Yeah. I thought you both looked out of character as well. I thought maybe you didn't know the camera was getting you. I think we did it.
有一刻，我甚至都没有试图掩饰。我简直是靠在他的肩膀上，更多地在看别的东西。没错。没错。我觉得你们俩看起来也很不符合各自的人设。我还以为你当时不知道摄像机拍到了你呢。我想我们确实知道了。
And then when we did, I stand up and I look, I turn around. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. So busted and accounting. We also got this question from Nathan S in Ontario who said, Pam explains in the cold open that the gym and personator is Steve an actor friend of ours. I just realized in season two,
然后当我们发现的时候，我站直了身子，然后看了一下，转过身去。对。对，对。所以会计部门当场被抓包。我们还收到了来自安大略省的内森·S的提问，他说，帕姆在开场短剧中解释说，扮演吉姆的那个人是史蒂夫，也就是我们的演员朋友。我刚刚意识到在第二季里，
booze crews when gym puts all of Dwight's belongings in the vending machine. Dwight tells Jim, I know you did this because you're friends with the vending machine guy and Jim replies, who, Steve? So I have to ask, while Steve is a common first name, does Jim have two friends name, Steve? One that is a vending machine guy and one that is an actor or is this actor also a vending machine guy? I like to think actor or is this actor also a vending machine guy. I like to think they're the same person. I like to think that they're the same as well. You know what? When I was growing up, I had a friend in grade school and her dad, his job was placing and stocking
游轮那一集，当吉姆把德怀特所有的东西都塞进自动售货机时。德怀特告诉吉姆，我知道是你干的，因为你跟自动售货机那家伙是朋友，而吉姆回答说，谁，史蒂夫？所以我不得不问，虽然史蒂夫是个很常见的名字，但吉姆有两个叫史蒂夫的朋友吗？一个是自动售货机那家伙，另一个是演员，还是说这个演员同时也是搞自动售货机的那个家伙？我宁愿相信演员……或者说这个演员同时也是自动售货机的那个家伙？我宁愿相信他们是同一个人。我也宁愿相信他们是同一个人。你知道吗？我小的时候，上小学时有个朋友，她爸爸的工作就是摆放和补货
the machines that you like put a quarter in and you get a bouncy ball. Oh yeah. Are you get candy? Yeah. And it was so crazy because they had extras of these machines like in their garage. Oh, in their living room. Like just around their house. And so I'd go over to a house to play and he had him where you didn't need to put a quarter in. And so if you wanted some sweet tarts, you'd just go over and crank it and get some sweet tarts.
那些你投币一个四分之一美元就能得到一个弹力球的机器。哦，对。或者能得到糖果？对。太疯狂了，因为他们家车库里居然还有这些机器的备用机。哦，在他们的客厅里。就像随处可见一样。所以我去某个朋友家玩时，他家里的机器甚至不需要投币。如果你想吃酸甜软糖，走过去转一下手柄就能拿到了。
I was like, you are the luckiest person in the whole world. Yeah, you live in a magical land. Yes. Do you want a spider ring? Right over by the couch. Oh my gosh. Amazing, right? Yeah.
当时我就觉得，你简直是世界上最幸运的人。对啊，你简直住在魔法世界里。没错。你要不要一个蜘蛛戒指？就在沙发旁边。我的天啊，太神奇了，对吧？对。
Pretty cool. So this episode starts with Erin and Darryl. They're both in the break room. They're study buddies. Yeah. She's trying to learn French. I guess everyone in Andy's family speaks multiple languages. And Darryl is reading a book.
酷得很。所以这一集是从艾琳和达里尔开始的。他们都在休息室里。他们是学习搭档。对。她正在学法语。我猜安迪家里的每个人都会好几种语言。而达里尔正在看一本书。
It's like, life hacks. How to become more efficient? He said he saved 90 seconds brushing his teeth in the shower. Mm-hmm. Lady, do you brush your teeth in the shower? No, but I know people who do. Do you? I have to save time. And Josh is like, that's disgusting. And then last night I went down the rabbit hole and like, how common is this? Do people do this? It might be the only one. It's a very divisive topic online. I want you to know.
就像是生活黑客。如何变得更高效？他说他在淋浴时刷牙节省了90秒。嗯。女士，你在淋浴时刷牙吗？不，但我认识这么做的人。你呢？我得节约时间。然后乔什就说，太恶心了。接着昨晚我深入研究了一下，这到底有多普遍？大家真的这么做吗？我可能是唯一一个。网上对这个话题争议很大。我想让你们知道。
What's the vice of about it? Well, a lot of people in the dental profession say that your shower has more bacteria. It's like a disgusting breeding place for bacteria and you should not keep a toothbrush in there. But what if you keep the toothbrush somewhere else and just bring it in with you? That is their recommendation. Definitely do that. I pee in the shower. I know you said that.
这有什么好争议的？嗯，牙科行业的很多人说，你的淋浴间有更多细菌。那就像是一个恶心的细菌滋生地，你绝不应该把牙刷放在里面。但如果你把牙刷放在别处，只在洗澡时拿进来呢？这就是他们的建议。绝对要那样做。我在淋浴时小便。我知道你这么说过。
If I have to go, the drain is right there. Come on. Most people do it. Do you not? I pee. Never? I mean, I... I am Cassie.
如果我有尿意，下水道就在那儿。拜托。大多数人都会这么做。难道你不会吗？我小便。从来没有？我是说，我……我是卡西。
I have not. Who else pees in the shower? Who wants to share? Sam gave me a hug. Oh yeah, absolutely. I have a gift. Thank you. Sam, I know I could count on you.
我没有。还有谁在淋浴时小便？谁想分享一下？山姆给了我一个拥抱。哦，对，当然。我有个礼物。谢谢。山姆，我知道我可以指望你。
Wait, wait. Do either of you ever brush your teeth in the shower? Yep. Thank you, C. Sam, I'm pe's good. Thank you. Thank you Sam, I know I could count on you. I think I could count on you. Wait, wait, to either of you ever brush your teeth in the shower? Yep. Thank you, see, see, yeah. And brush your teeth in the shower. Well, here's the thing, I don't know if any of you
等等，等等。你们俩有没有人在淋浴时刷牙？有。谢谢，C。山姆，我小便很好。谢谢。谢谢山姆，我知道我可以指望你。我想我可以指望你。等等，等等，你们俩有没有人在淋浴时刷牙？有。谢谢，看，看，对。还在淋浴时刷牙。好吧，是这样的，我不知道你们中间有没有人
out there listening have this issue, but when I'm in water, my body can't release water. You've talked about your problem peeing in the ocean. It's very hard for my brain to allow it to happen. There's no way I would have to be in a dire situation to pee in the shower, because my body is like, lock it up. Okay, I get that when I'm submerged in water. It's very hard for me.
在听的人有这个问题，但当我在水里时，我的身体就无法排水。你曾经谈过你在海里小便的问题。我的大脑很难让这件事发生。绝对不可能，我必须处于非常绝望的情况才会选择在淋浴时小便，因为我的身体就像是，彻底锁死了。好吧，当我完全浸在水里时我也有这种感觉。这对我来说太难了。
I have a very hard time peeing in the ocean. But I can pee in a shower. It's running water, the sound of it. It's almost like if I get in the shower and I don't even think I have to pee, the sound of it triggers something. No. For me, my body's like, lock it up. Hmm. You can brush your teeth, but you cannot pee. Well, maybe don't brush your teeth in my shower, but how often do you brush your teeth in the shower? Several times a week if I'm running late. If I'm running late, I just make it all happen in the shower. How is it make it faster? I don't understand. Okay, here's what I do. I put my conditioner in my hair. I like to let it set for a little bit
我在海里小便非常困难。但我可以在淋浴时小便。那是流动的流水声。几乎就像我走进淋浴间，甚至觉得自己不需要小便，流水声就会触发某种机制。不。对我来说，我的身体就像是，锁死了。嗯。你可以刷牙，但你不能小便。好吧，也许不要在我的淋浴间刷牙，但你多久在淋浴间刷牙一次？如果我要迟到了，一周好几次。如果我要迟到了，我就把所有事情都在淋浴间搞定。这怎么能更快呢？我不明白。好吧，我是这么做的。我把护发素抹在头发上。我喜欢让它停留一会儿
because you know I get my hair highlighted. So I have a conditioner I put on the ends and that's when I do my other business. I brush my teeth, I shave my legs. That's multitasking. Okay, there you go. All right, that is not a perplexing thing. You're like, mm, okay. What? I don't know. I guess I'm always busy in the shower. I don't feel like I have any downtime.
因为你知道我的头发漂染过。所以我会用一种护发素涂在发梢上，那个时候我就顺便处理其他事情。我刷牙，我刮腿毛。这就是多任务处理。好吧，这就对了。好吧，这并不是什么令人困惑的事。你可能会觉得，嗯，好吧。什么？我不知道。我猜我在淋浴时总是很忙。我觉得自己没有任何空闲时间。
So I don't feel like it's saving me anything to add a task. I don't have downtime. I'm making use of while the conditioner's on me. I know, I don't do the conditioner thing. I guess it's what I'm saying. I have some tidbits about the book that Daryl is reading. The Lifehack book? Yes, it's a real book.
所以我并不觉得增加一项任务能帮我省下什么时间。我没有空闲时间。我只是在利用抹护发素的这段时间。我知道，我不用护发素那套。我想这就是我想说的。我有一些关于达里尔正在读的那本书的花絮。那本生活黑客书？是的，那是一本真书。
It's called Getting Things Done, The Art of Stress-Free Productivity. It's by an author named David Allen. His whole thing is like just helping you find ways to bring productivity into your life and also help you be more present. Well, we all need that. Well, we have our favorite.
书名叫《尽管去做：无压工作的艺术》。作者叫戴维·艾伦。他的核心理念就是帮助你找到方法，把高效融入生活，同时也帮你变得更加活在当下。好吧，我们都需要这个。嗯，我们确实有最爱。
And we do. She is my personal coach and yours for organizing life and getting stuff done. It's Kendra Adachi. She has a podcast and a book called The Lazy Genius. It's really brilliant because it's also simple and that makes it easy to apply to your life. It's be a genius at the things you care about and be lazy at the things that don't matter to you. She has episodes on like every topic. She had one recently that was like seven ways to manage daily chaos or how to
我们确实有。她是我的私人教练，也是你们的教练，教你如何整理生活并把事情做好。她就是肯德拉·阿达奇。她有一个播客和一本书，名叫《懒人天才》。这真的很棒，因为它既简单又容易应用到你的生活中。在你在乎的事情上做个天才，在那些对你不重要的事情上做个懒人。她有关于各种主题的单集。她最近有一集是关于管理日常混乱的七种方法，或者是如何
create a relaxing routine. I just listened to one where she talked about five steps to just better improve your work life. And I'm already using two of the steps and it's already changing my life. This is what we're saying everybody. If we were Darryl, we would be just... We'd be reading the lazy genius. Exactly. Lady, let's put a link to her podcast in our stories this week. Oh, for sure. All right. Darrell has a talking head where he explains that the reason he's doing all this is because he has been named assistant regional manager.
建立一个放松的常规。我刚刚听了一期，她谈到了改善工作生活的五个步骤。我已经在使用其中两个步骤了，它已经在改变我的生活了。这就是我们要对大家说的。如果我们是达里尔，我们就会……我们就会去读《懒人天才》。没错。女士们，我们这周在动态里放一个通往她播客的链接吧。哦，当然。好了。达里尔有一个单独的访谈镜头，他解释说自己做这一切的原因是因为他被任命为了助理地区经理。
Yeah. In fact, you know what would be helpful to him and more efficient would be if he could do a few sound bites and get him out of the way for the rest of the day, so he does one. Oh, there were so many more that he did in the shooting draft they made it into deleted scenes on the DVD. I felt like this episode in particular,
对。事实上，你知道什么对他更有帮助、更有效率吗，那就是如果他能录几段独白，然后把这事搞定，剩下的时间就能解放出来，所以他就录了一段。哦，他们在拍摄初稿里还拍了更多这样的镜头，后来它们作为删减片段被收录在DVD里。我觉得这一集特别
there's a few other moments I'm gonna share where they're really starting to break the fourth wall. We saw this already where Jim and Pam addressed the camera crew about their summer. And I know it's intentional because you wanna start seeing the camera crew in their presence more in the show. Listen to Darryl give them a ton of sound bites.
还有一些其他的时刻我要分享，他们真的开始打破第四面墙了。我们之前就见过吉姆和帕姆向摄像团队谈论他们的夏天。我知道这是刻意安排的，因为你想在剧中更多地看到摄像团队在场的存在感。听听达里尔给他们贡献了大量的独白吧。
Let's play the clip. Sister Andy promoted me to assistant regional manager. I've been trying to step up my game, be more productive. In fact, you know what? Let's knock out a few more of these sound bites while we're here. Whoa. That person has found him or herself in quiet a predicament. Oh, that told me, when will he ever learn?
我们放一下这个片段。安迪副经理提拔我做了助理地区经理。我一直在努力提升表现，变得更高产。事实上，你知道吗？趁我们在这儿，再多录几段独白吧。哇。那个人发现自己陷入了一种相当尴尬的境地。哦，这告诉我，他什么时候才能吸取教训呢？
Andy, Andy, Andy. I can't believe Kevin swallowed a pin. I can't believe Kevin swallowed another pin. And then it cuts to a scene of Kevin swallowing a pin. No. And I remember when we filmed this poor Brian had a kind of like slowly inhale a pin, like little, little, little, little, little, little. And then he starts to choke and Oscar goes and hits the back of his head and he spits
安迪，安迪，安迪。真不敢相信凯文吞了一枚别针。真不敢相信凯文又吞了一枚别针。然后镜头切到一个凯文吞别针的场景。不。我还记得我们拍这场戏时，可怜的布莱恩不得不做出一种慢慢吸入别针的样子，一小点、一小点、一小点、一小点、一小点、一小点。然后他开始噎住，奥斯卡走过去拍拍他的后背，他把它
it out. Oh, I think I remember this. And then there's like a few minutes later, he starts doing it again and my character is like, what are you doing? But I loved hearing Daryl's different soundbites. Well, while Aaron is practicing French in the break room, Dwight comes in. He's like, that's a great language if you're a chain smoking acrobat. He says, off French, it's a great language. I know, sorry, that made me laugh.
吐了出来。哦，我想我记得这个。然后过了几分钟，他又开始这么做了，我的角色就说，你在干什么？但我很喜欢听达里尔不同的独白。好吧，正当艾琳在休息室练习法语时，德怀特进来了。他说，如果你是一个连环吸烟的杂技演员，那这真是一门极好的语言。他说，少来点法语，这是一门伟大的语言。我知道，抱歉，那逗笑我了。
Shout out though to Ellie Kimper because her French was so hilarious. Yeah. It sounded like she was having like her whole body was having a moment. A little little it was crazy. Do I suggest she learned Dothraki if she wants to impress a man? Yeah. He has a talking head. He says it's the language spoken on game of thrones. You know I had to geek out at this moment. I geeked out when we filmed it. I was already a Game of Thrones fan. I had already been callisi for Halloween. I didn't know what any of it meant when we filmed it. I know, honey.
不过要向艾莉·肯珀致敬，因为她的法语太搞笑惹。对。听起来好像她全身都在经历某种时刻。一点点，太疯狂了。德怀特建议如果她想给一个男人留下深刻印象，就去学多斯拉克语。对。他有一个单独的访谈。他说那是《权力的游戏》里说的语言。你知道我在这个时刻绝对是个极客发作了。我们拍摄时我就极客发作了。我当时已经是《权力的游戏》的粉丝了。我万圣节时就已经扮演过丹妮莉丝了。我们拍摄时我甚至不知道这到底是什么意思。我知道，亲爱的。
We did have a fan catch from the scene from Laurel F in Phoenix, Arizona, who said that Erin is using a coffee mug that says Northern Light and that there is a real Northern Light espresso bar in Cafe in Scranton. It has the same logo as Erin's mug. Hey, so local Scranton mug. Dwight is going to start teaching Erin Dothraki. Yes. And we had a fan question from Callin' S in Ann Arbor Arbor Michigan who said what was the process like of getting permission to mention Game of Thrones and Dothraki in this episode and were any other fictional languages considered. Well Steve Burgess said that there was no problem mentioning Game of Thrones. The legal department didn't say anything.
我们确实收到了来自亚利桑那州凤凰城的劳伦·F的一个粉丝线索，她说艾琳用的咖啡杯上写着“北极光”，而在斯克兰顿真的有一家名为“北极光”的意式浓缩咖啡吧和咖啡馆。它的标志和艾琳杯子上的完全一样。嘿，这是一个地道的斯克兰顿杯子。德怀特要开始教艾琳多斯拉克语了。是的。我们收到了来自密歇根州安阿伯市的科林·S的一个粉丝问题，他问在这集中获得提及《权力的游戏》和多斯拉克语的授权过程是怎样的，还有没有考虑过其他虚构语言。好吧，史蒂夫·伯吉斯说提到《权力的游戏》没有任何问题。法务部门什么也没说。
He thinks maybe because we weren't saying anything derogatory, and we also did not consider any other fake languages. Angela, I think we both did a deep dive on Dothraki. I know you did. Oh, I had to look it up just to get some basics, but I think you went deeper. Let me tell you guys, sometimes we look ahead to see like, oh, what episodes are coming up? And when I saw this a month ago, I started watching videos. And we'll share a little bit of that with you. Well, for all of y'all out there who might lean a little closer to a Jenna than an Angela, the Dothraki language is a fictional language. In George our our Martins fantasy novel series, a song of ice and fire, and its television adaptation Game of Thrones. The language
他认为可能是因为我们没有说任何贬损的话，而且我们也没有考虑过任何其他虚构语言。安吉拉，我想我们俩都对多斯拉克语进行了深度挖掘。我知道你做了。哦，我不得不查阅一下来掌握一些基础知识，但我觉得你挖得更深。我来告诉你们大家，有时我们会向前看，看看有哪些即将播出的剧集？一个月前我看到这个时，我就开始看视频了。我们会和你们分享其中的一小部分。好吧，对于你们所有人中可能更偏向詹娜而不是安吉拉的人来说，多斯拉克语是一种虚构语言。在乔治·R·R·马丁的奇幻小说系列《冰与火之歌》及其改编电视剧《权力的游戏》中，这种语言
of Dothraki was created by linguist David J. Peterson for the Game of Thrones. He explained that the grammar is most similar to Russian, but that the vocabulary was heavily inspired by the Genghis Khan Mongolian language to reflect the nomadic lifestyle of the Dothraki people. I mean, it's already so fascinating, right? Yes. I mean, I guess there were so many words that were in the novel, but it wasn't enough for a full language for people on a TV show to speak it.
多斯拉克语是由语言学家大卫·J·彼得森为《权力的游戏》创造的。他解释说，其语法与俄语最相似，但词汇深受成吉思汗蒙古语的启发，以反映多斯拉克人游牧的生活方式。我的意思是，这已经非常吸引人了，对吧？是的。我的意思是，我猜小说里有很多词，但这还不足够让电视剧里的人们用它来进行完整的交流。
There were a handful of words, but they needed to create a language. Yes. So, I found so many great articles about David J. Peterson and how he came to develop these languages, but I have to tell you a little something. What is it? I met David a few years ago. How? Okay.
只有区区几个词，但他们需要创造一门语言。是的。所以，我找到了很多关于大卫·J·彼得森以及他是如何开发这些语言的精彩文章，但我必须告诉你们一件小事。什么事？我几年前见过大卫。怎么见到的？好吧。
He was a contestant on the game show to tell the truth when I was a judge. It was me, Donald Fazon, Ashley Graham, and Jalen Rose. You remember the show, there were the judges, and then there were three people who would claim to be something, and only one would be telling the truth and the other two were lying and the judges had to guess. Yes, I've been on to tell the truth as well. I know.
当我当评委的时候，他是游戏节目《实话实说》的参赛者。当时有我、唐纳德·法森、阿什利·格雷厄姆和杰伦·罗斯。你还记得这个节目吧，有评委，然后有三个人声称自己是某种身份，只有一个说的是真话，另外两个在撒谎，评委必须猜出来。是的，我也上过《实话实说》。我知道。
So in this particular episode, there were three contestants that came out and said that they created the Dothraki language for Game of Thrones. Okay. And we had to ask them all questions and then guess who the real creator was. I found the episode online. Do you want to know who guessed correctly and incorrectly?
所以在这一集里，有三位参赛者走上前来，声称他们为《权力的游戏》创造了多斯拉克语。好吧。然后我们必须问他们所有人问题，接着猜谁才是真正的创造者。我在网上找到了这一集。你想知道谁猜对了，谁猜错了嘛？
Did you guess correctly? I did! I bet! I did! I bet! I did! I guess correctly. And so did Donald Faeson and Jalen and Ashley got it wrong. I bet you asked good questions. Thank you, lady.
你猜对了吗？我猜对了！我敢打赌！我猜对了！我敢打赌！我猜对了！我猜对了。唐纳德·法森、杰伦也猜对了，阿什利猜错了。我敢打赌你问了很好的问题。谢谢你，女士。
Anyway, I wanted to go up to him so desperately, but they moved the show along, but I think I did a thing like, hey, hey, like a wave, like, hey! Wow. Yeah, it was so cool. Then he did an interview with Vanity Fair where first of all, he explains how he got the job. And then he listens to other people trying to speak
总之，我非常想走过去找他，但节目进行得太快了，不过我想我做了一个这样的动作，嘿，嘿，就像挥手一样，嘿！哇。是的，太酷了。后来他接受了《名利场》的采访，首先，他是怎么得到这份工作的。然后他听了其他人试图说
Dothraki and gives his analysis of their attempts and he addresses Dwighton Arons. Really? Yes, all of their scenes. He was very impressed with our writers and their research of the language. Let's hear him in this interview. The producers of Game of Thrones contacted the language creation society who then put together
多斯拉克语，并对他们的尝试给出了分析，他还提到了德怀特·阿朗。真的吗？是的，所有这些场景。他对我们的编剧以及他们对语言的研究印象深刻。让我们听听他在这次采访中的话。《权力的游戏》制作人联系了语言创造协会，协会随后组织了一场
a competition and announced it to the language creators all over the world online. I then was one of the finalists that emerged. There were five finalists that were picked. And then the producers chose from that set of finalists and they chose mine. So I became the official creator of Dothraki for Game of Thrones. And now this is Dwight Shrewd teaching Aaron how to speak Dothraki. I throat rip. Fourth Agandak. You throat rip.
比赛，并在网上向全世界的语言创作者宣布。然后我成为了脱颖而出的决赛选手之一。选出了五位决赛选手。然后制作人从这组决赛选手挑选了我的。所以我成为了《权力的游戏》中多斯拉克语的官方创造者。现在这是德怀特·施鲁德教亚伦怎么说多斯拉克语。我锁喉。第四阿甘达克。你锁喉。
Fourth Agandi. He she it throat ribs. Fourth Agandak. More of a barbaric growl. Fourth Agandak. Louder. You're shouting it from the back of a horse. Fourth Agandak. More of a barbaric growl. Vuh! Again, doc! Louder, you're shouting it from the back of a horse! Vuh! Again, doc!
第四阿甘迪。他她它锁喉。第四阿甘达克。更像是野蛮的咆哮。第四阿甘达克。大声点。你是从马背上喊出来的。第四阿甘达克。更像是野蛮的咆哮。Vuh！再次，达克！大声点，你是从马背上喊出来的！Vuh！再次，达克！
Okay, so first this construction was not something that I'd ever imagined for Dothraki. Whoever was a writer of this episode really kind of studied the grammar. And so they created something pretty interesting and I was like, alright, I'll go with that noun incorporation. You did it right, so let's do it. And so I made that a part of the Dothraki language after that, I call it the shrutian compound. I don't know if I ever got to use it on the show. I don't think I did. There wasn't much Dothraki after this thing here. So to the writers of the
好吧，所以首先这种结构是我从未为多斯拉克语想象过的。这一集的编剧真的很好地研究了语法。所以他们创造了一些非常有趣的东西，我想，好吧，我接受这种名词结合。你做对了，那我们就这样做吧。所以我后来把这成为了多斯拉克语的一部分，我称之为施鲁德复合词。我不知道我有没有在剧里用过。我想我没有。这里之后就没有多少多斯拉克语了。所以对《办公室》的
office, thank you very much for actually studying this to make sure that the Dothraki was correct, but not a thank you for not inviting me to the set, was a deal. I found out because I watched it live. Literally, that's how I found out. Come on, man, throw me a bone. And then Aaron, your pronunciation was pretty good. Just be sure you get the stress right.
编剧们，非常感谢你们实际研究了这一点，以确保多斯拉克语是正确的，但是没有邀请我去片场，这可就不太友好了。我发现是因为我看的是直播。字面意思，我就是这么发现的。拜托，老兄，给我点面子。然后亚伦，你的发音相当不错。只要确保音调正确就行。
So I'm not too much E.J. Eddie. Good job. Wow. Yeah, isn't that great? I am so impressed with our writers. I know! They don't phone anything in. And now, part of the Dothraki language
所以我不是很太E.J.埃迪。干得好。哇。是啊，不是很棒吗？我对我们的编剧印象深刻。我知道！他们做事从不敷衍。现在，多斯拉克语的一部分
was created on the office, a tiny part, but there's a compounded now now. Look at how excited you are. I'm very excited. That your worlds of the office and Game of Thrones have collided. Have had a crossover. They have. I'm gid excited. That your worlds of the office and Game of Thrones have collided. I've had a crossover. They have.
是在《办公室》里创造的，一小部分，但现在有了一个复合词。看你多兴奋。我非常兴奋。你们的《办公室》和《权力的游戏》世界碰撞了。有了一次交叉联动。确实有。我很激动。你们的《办公室》和《权力的游戏》世界碰撞了。有了一次交叉联动。确实有。
I'm giddy about it. That was very cool. Yeah. So now we're gonna go over to Pam's desk where Nelly is very distracting. She's just sort of like tapping her pen. Yeah. And we come to find out that she has to take her driver's test
我为此感到兴奋。那真的很酷。是的。所以现在我们要去帕姆的桌子旁，奈莉在那里非常分散注意力。她只是在敲钢笔。是的。然后我们发现她必须参加驾照考试
in a few days. She needs to practice, but she hasn't had any time to do this thanks to Demandee. Yeah. And Pam is gonna offer to go driving with her at lunch. Yeah, she's like, sorry, Jim. I won't be here for lunch. And he's like, that's okay, I have a thing of soup.
几天后。她需要练习，但由于曼迪，她一直没时间这样做。是的。帕姆提出中午和她一起去开车。是的，她说，对不起，吉姆。我午饭不在。他说，没关系，我有一份汤。
I have a thing of soup. You know what? Fuck you, Jim. You know that you're keeping something from Pam. You know she's on to you. We don't need your little like. I have a thing tease of soup. Put it away, dude. What is that? I think he slips and then has to back pedal. I don't know. To me, he looks at back pedal. I don't know. But he looks at the camera. He looks at the camera.
我有一份汤。你知道吗？操你的，吉姆。你知道你在对帕姆隐瞒什么。你知道她已经察觉了。我们不需要你那种。我有一份汤的调侃。收起来吧，老兄。那是什么？我觉得他口误了，然后不得不改口。我不知道。在我看来，他在试图圆场。我不知道。但他看着镜头。他看着镜头。
I don't know. I'm sorry guys, but the part of me that is Pam is not real happy with Jim over this week's long secret that is changing their lives. I have a hot tip. What is it? If you're gonna lie, don't say I have a thing of soup. Uh-huh. It's not a good one.
我不知道。我很抱歉，伙计们，但是身为帕姆的那部分我对于吉姆本周长期的秘密并不是很高兴，这正在改变他们的生活。我有一个内幕消息。是什么？如果你要撒谎，别说我有一份汤。呃-哈。这不是个好借口。
Do you think he's lying? I thought he was teasing her. I thought he was like, that's okay. I have a thing of soup. No. I know you keep asking me if I have a secret and I keep telling you I don't. No, no, no. I think he forgot in that moment and he slipped up.
你觉得他在撒谎吗？我以为他在逗她。我以为他在说，没关系。我有一份汤。不。我知道你一直在问我有没有秘密，而我一直告诉你我没有。不，不，不。我想他在那一刻忘记了，他口误了。
And then I think his cover is soup. I think his I have a thing was honest and then he caught himself and he had to say soup. Well you know what? Look at your wife's face for one second and realize that you're breaking her heart. I know. Thing of soup. I can't keep secrets like that. You know what? Thing of soup is not hope in a frame. It sure isn't Angela. Put that on a pillow. Ha ha ha ha ha.
然后我想他的掩饰是汤。我想他的“我有一份”是诚实的，然后他反应过来，不得不说汤。好吧，你知道吗？看一眼你妻子的脸，意识到你正在打破她的心。我知道。一份汤。我无法保守这样的秘密。你知道吗？“一份汤”可不是框里的希望。确实不是，安吉拉。把它绣在枕头上。哈哈哈哈哈。
Ah, well before Nelly goes driving, she's gonna have a meeting with Andy. Yes. I would like to point out something here. What is it? I feel like Nelly is Andy's Pam, the way Pam was with Michael, except Michael would have all these random projects for Pam, but they were earnest.
啊，好吧，在奈莉去开车之前，她要和安迪开个会。是的。我想在这里指出一件事。什么事？我觉得奈莉是安迪的帕姆，就像当年帕姆对迈克尔那样，只不过迈克尔会给帕姆所有这些随机的项目，但它们是认真的。
Whereas Andy has all these ridiculous tasks for Nelly, but they're spiteful. I don't know, is asking her to do his genealogy a spiteful thing? Like, is he doing that just because? I think it's busy work. He's demanding. So there were more scenes in the shooting draft. Not only did he ask her to produce childproof paper that doesn't give you paper cuts, which is impossible, he also asked her to make as many different types of hats as possible out of a piece of paper.
而安迪给奈莉所有这些荒谬的任务，但它们是恶意的。我不知道，让她做他的家谱是一件恶意的事吗？就像，他这么做只是因为？我认为这是消磨时间的活。他太苛刻了。所以在拍摄剧本中有更多场景。他不仅要求她制作不会割破手指的儿童安全纸，这根本不可能，他还要求她用一张纸尽可能多地制作不同类型的帽子。
So she spent half the day trying to make hats out of paper. Yeah. And then she did the genealogy thing. Andy doesn't even want to read the genealogy report. He just wants the highlights. And so she reveals you are a distant relative of Michelle Obama. Yeah. Andy could not be more excited. Oh, he is so thrilled. He makes a huge announcement to the bullpen. He says, my fellow Americans, I have a feeling my approval rating is about to go through the roof. Hello Americans, I have a feeling my approval rating is about to go through the roof. He thinks this is going to catapult him.
所以她花了一半的时间试图用纸做帽子。是的。然后她做了家谱的事。安迪甚至不想读家谱报告。他只想看亮点。于是她透露你是米歇尔·奥巴马的远亲。是的。安迪兴奋极了。哦，他太激动了。他向全体员工发布了一个重大公告。他说，我的美国同胞们，我感觉我的支持率要飙升了。你好，美国同胞们，我感觉我的支持率要飙升了。他认为这会让他平步青云。
Yeah. In the shooting draft, it's also in deleted scenes. He then sits down and writes Michelle Obama a letter. No, he doesn't. Yes, he does. What does it say? I'm going to read it. Andy reads aloud as he writes, dear Michelle, how are you?
是的。在拍摄剧本中，这也在被删减的片段中。然后他坐下来给米歇尔·奥巴马写了一封信。不，他没有。不，他写了。上面写了什么？我要读一下。安迪边写边大声读出来，亲爱的米歇尔，你好吗？
I am fine. My name is Andrew Bernard and I recently discovered that we are related. I want you to know the rest of the family is so proud of you for all that you have achieved. As for me, I currently manage one branch of a mid-level paper company. If you'd like to meet, I can come to DC any Saturday except October 20th due to a previous commitment. Hope. And then he looks to camera.
我很好。我叫安德鲁·伯纳德，我最近发现我们有亲戚关系。我想让你知道，家里的其他人为你所取得的一切成就感到非常骄傲。至于我，我目前管理着一家中型纸业公司的一个分公司。如果你想见面，我任何星期六都可以去华盛顿，除了10月20日，因为之前有安排。希望。然后他看着镜头。
I put that in all capital letters. Hope to see you soon, but again, not on the 20th. Love Andy Benart. That is amazing. I know. It got me so tickled. In your youth, did you ever write a famous person a letter? A fan letter or any kind of letter?
我把所有字母都大写了。希望很快能见到你，但再说一次，20号不行。爱你的安迪·伯纳德。太棒了。我知道。这让我觉得很有趣。在你年轻的时候，你给名人写过信吗？粉丝信还是别的什么信？
Well, I had heard that if you invite the president to your wedding, if you send them a formal invitation, you get a reply back. Mm-hmm. And I did that. Did you get a reply? I did. Oh! Sorry, we're unable to attend.
嗯，我听说如果你邀请总统参加你的婚礼，如果你给他们发一份正式的邀请函，你会得到回复。嗯。我这么做了。你收到回复了吗？我收到了。哦！抱歉，我们无法出席。
You're wedding. Oh, my goodness. We wish you all the best. That is a person full-time job. I did. Oh, sorry, we're unable to attend. You're wetting it. Oh my goodness. We wish you all the best. That is a person's full-time job. I know. You would love that job. I would. You would just get wetting invitations all day. So many wax stamps.
你的婚礼。哦，天哪。我们祝你一切顺利。那是一个人的全职工作。我收到了。哦，抱歉，我们无法出席。你的婚礼。哦，天哪。我们祝你一切顺利。那是一个人的全职工作。我知道。你会喜欢那份工作的。我会的。你整天都会收到婚礼邀请函。好多蜡印。
I know. Little confetti's Angela all day. I know, all day. Oh my gosh, how do we get you that job? I know. I know. I just open, oh, that is a perfect retirement job. You have a stack of the presidential seal responses. Mm-hmm.
我知道。安吉拉一整天都在撒彩纸。我知道，一整天。天哪，我们怎么才能帮你找到那份工作？我知道。我知道。我只要一打开，哦，那简直是一份完美的退休工作。你有一叠总统印章的回信。嗯哼。
You open people's wedding invites. I bet I could have a window, have my hummingbird feeder. Ladies. This is a perfect job for me. Wow. Well, Erin is completely intimidated by this news. Yeah. She's gonna have to see the first lady at holidays now? Yeah, what is she gonna say at holiday dinners? Oh my goodness. The pressure.
你打开别人的婚礼请柬。我敢打赌，我可以有个窗户，装上我的蜂鸟喂食器。女士们。这对我来说是一份完美的工作。哇。好吧，艾琳对这个消息感到完全畏惧。是的。她现在在节假日得见到第一夫人了？是的，她在节日晚宴上会说什么？哦天哪。这压力。
In the break room, Andy tells Clark and Pete that he's getting rid of all the junk food because in case they hadn't heard, he's now related to Michelle Obama. They applaud him. Yes. Turns out they applaud him all the time. All the time. Well, Andy wants to remove this junk food partly because now he has this very strong connection to one of Michelle Obama's initiatives that we need to get healthier. There was a scene. It's indelated scenes and I had never heard this term before and now I just want to use it for the rest of my life. Andy flexes in front
在休息室里，安迪告诉克拉克和皮特，他要清理掉所有的垃圾食品，因为他们可能没听说，他现在和米歇尔·奥巴马是亲戚。他们为他鼓掌。是的。结果他们随时都在为他鼓掌。随时。好吧，安迪想要拿走这些垃圾食品，部分是因为现在他和米歇尔·奥巴马的一项倡议有了非常紧密的联系，我们需要变得更健康。有个场景。这是删减片段，我以前从未听过这个词，现在我只想在余生中一直使用它。安迪在大家面前
of everyone. You know, he comes out of my life. Andy flexes in front of everyone. You know, he comes out of his office and he does like the flex. Sure, shows off his biceps. And then he shouts to the room. He says, I want someone to come slap my hang down. What's that mean? Jim says, what's a hang down?
展示肌肉。你知道，他从我的生活里走出来。安迪在大家面前展示肌肉。你知道，他从办公室出来，然后做了一个秀肌肉的动作。当然，展示他的二头肌。然后他向房间里大喊。他说，我要有人来拍我的松弛肉。那是什么意思？吉姆说，什么是松弛肉？
And he said, it's the part that hangs down, you know, from your bicep. You're triceps? Yeah, yeah, right here. Yeah. He's like, someone come slap my hang down because, you know, he's sort of like, it's so rock hard, right?
他说，就是那个从你二头肌垂下来的部位，你知道的。你的三头肌？对，对，就在这里。对。他就像是，来个人拍拍我的松弛肉，因为，你知道的，他觉得，它硬得像石头一样，对吧？
So I'm gonna hurt. Meredith walks over and slaps the shit out of this. Oh my gosh! Hang down and Andy's like, ow! But I mean, I had never heard that part of your body called the hang down. I've got some hang down. I've got some hang down. I've got some hang down
所以我会受伤。梅雷迪思走过去，狠狠地拍了一下这个。哦天哪！松弛肉，安迪就说，哎哟！但我的意思是，我从来没听过你身体的那部分叫松弛肉。我也有点松弛肉。我也有点松弛肉。我也有点松弛肉。
You know what? I think to myself thank goodness. I'm not you know part of the royal family where I have to put my arm up and wave Because then you just see a jiggly hang down. Oh, you know what I mean? Yeah, I had thank goodness That's the only reason I'm glad I'm not part of a royal family Everything else I could handle. You could do everything else. I could do all the rest of it, but with my broken children, my hang down, I'd have a hard time waving.
你知道吗？我心里想，谢天谢地。我不是那种需要举起手臂挥手的王室成员，因为那样你就会看到晃动的松弛肉。哦，你知道我的意思吗？是的，我有谢天谢地。这是我庆幸自己不是王室成员的唯一原因。其他一切我都能应付。其他一切你都能应付。其余的我都行，但拖着我残破的孩子们和松弛肉，我挥手可就费劲了。
Otherwise, you would be in. Count you in. One of my mom's sisters years ago, my aunt, I'll never forget, she had reached a certain age and it was so hot out and she had a long sleeve on. And I was like, what are you doing in long sleeve? She's like, I haven't worn short sleeves in years. I was like, because of the hang down.
不然的话，你就会加入。算你一个。多年前我妈妈的一个姐妹，我阿姨，我永远不会忘记，她到了某个年纪，外面天气很热，她却穿着长袖。我就问，你穿长袖干嘛？她说，我好多年没穿短袖了。我说，因为松弛肉吗？
Because of the hang down. Here's what I'm gonna tell everybody. Let it hang down. Hang it down, let it flap. Hang it down now. Life is too short. Is this the fifties that we were talking about a few episodes ago, Angela?
因为松弛肉。我要告诉大家的是：让它垂着吧。垂着吧，让它晃荡吧。现在就垂着吧。人生苦短。安吉拉，这是我们几集前谈论的五十岁吗？
Yes. Like my just like body face, wrinkly neck, hang down body is just like, I'm just like, I'm fine. Bring it on. I'm fine. Worried about it in my forties in my fifties. I'm like just whatever. No, I have to tell y'all out there who are a lot younger than us when you get to your 50s. It's a real like liberating zero F's chapter. Yeah, we should all have started this in our 20s. Maybe the next generation will have some of it.
是的。就像我刚到身体发福、脖子起皱、松弛肉下垂的阶段，我就觉得，我挺好的。放马过来吧。我挺好的。四十岁时还担心这个，到了五十岁，我就觉得随它去吧。不，我得告诉你们这些比我们年轻得多的人，当你到了五十岁。这是一个真正解放的、完全不在乎的章节。是的，我们本该在二十岁就开始这样的生活。也许下一代会懂一些吧。
They'll figure it out. Yeah. Jim is now in Daryl's office and he's learning about batching and he's really into it. Andy comes in and Jim's like, you gotta see this, this is really cool. And Andy's like, I'm gonna need you to be canned tuna right now.
他们会想明白的。是的。吉姆现在在达里尔的办公室，他正在了解批量处理法，并且非常感兴趣。安迪走进来，吉姆说，你得看看这个，这真的很酷。安迪却说，我现在需要你变成一罐金枪鱼。
I don't wanna hear from you. Yeah, big tuna zip it. That's when Andy tells Daryl his good news. Daryl is skeptical. Yeah, but he's like, that's cool. I have a fun fact. Okay. Daryl is skeptical. Yeah, but he's like, that's cool. I have a fun fact. OK. Michelle Obama's brother is named Craig Robinson.
我不想听你废话。是的，大金枪鱼，闭嘴。就在那时，安迪把他的好消息告诉了达里尔。达里尔表示怀疑。是的，但他觉得，这挺酷的。我有个趣事。好吧。达里尔表示怀疑。是的，但他觉得，这挺酷的。我有个趣事。好吧。米歇尔·奥巴马的弟弟名叫克雷格·罗宾逊。
That's crazy. How about that? That's a crossover. It sure is. I also wanted everyone when you're rewatching this episode and you see this scene, to please note that there's a lot of background action in this scene. Cree does a cross to reception, Meredith is at the copier.
这太疯狂了。怎么样？这是一个跨界联动。确实是的。我还希望大家在重温这一集并看到这个场景时，请注意这个场景中有很多背景动作。克里穿过接待区，梅雷迪思在复印机旁。
The reason for this is because Rain and I could not be at our desks in the background, and if we didn't have all that crossing, it would have just looked like an empty office. But, you know, Pam is supposed to be teaching Nelly to drive, Dwight is supposed to be teaching Aaron Dothraki, so this is something that they would do to prevent empty backgrounds. And I thought this scene was a good example of it. I like it.
这样做的原因是雷恩和我不能坐在背景的办公桌前，如果我们没有所有这些穿行，看起来就会像一个空办公室。但是，你知道的，帕姆本该教内莉开车，德怀特本该教艾琳多斯拉克语，所以这是他们为了防止背景空无一人而会做的事情。我觉得这个场景就是一个很好的例子。我喜欢它。
Well, let's go to break because when we're back, Nelly is eating a salad while driving. Yeah. I have a list for you. Best foods to eat while driving. Wait for it. I can't wait for it, but I will wait for it. Best foods to eat while driving. Wait for it. I can't wait for it, but I will wait for it. We'll be right back.
好吧，我们去休息一下，因为回来后，内莉一边开车一边吃沙拉。是的。我给你列了个清单。开车时最适合吃的食物。拭目以待吧。我等不及了，但我会等的。开车时最适合吃的食物。拭目以待吧。我等不及了，但我会等的。我们马上回来。
[♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ We're back. Pam is in the passenger seat. Nelly is driving. And on the console between the two of them is an open takeout container with a salad. I don't know what kind of salad sees her salad. There's big croutons. Like how is she eating the salad in driving? You know what? It was scripted that she would be eating a
[♪ 片尾曲播放中 ♪] 我们回来了。帕姆坐在副驾驶座上。内莉在开车。两人之间的中控台上放着一个打开的外卖沙拉盒。我不知道是什么沙拉，看到她的沙拉了。有很大的面包丁。她是怎么一边开车一边吃沙拉的？你知道吗？剧本里写了她要吃一盘
salad specifically. It was scripted that it was in her lap. It was, yes, well, here's the thing. When we first did this scene, we did a take of Catherine holding the salad, like kind of in her lap slash. You could see it when it was on her lap. So then she was kind of holding it up. So we had some like visual issues
沙拉，具体就是这样。剧本里写了它放在她的腿上。是的，好吧，事情是这样的。当我们第一次拍这个场景时，我们拍了一个凯瑟琳拿着沙拉的镜头，差不多放在她的大腿上。当它放在她腿上时你能看到它。所以她有点把它举起来。所以我们遇到了一些视觉上的问题
because you know, we had those little lipstick camps and you know, they only show so much. So it's like where can we put the salad? Where it's clear that she's eating a salad. Yes, and we started with her kind of like holding it with one hand and having to take her hand off the wheel to eat it. And it was so funny.
因为你知道的，我们有那些小唇膏摄像机，你知道的，它们只能拍到那么多。所以就像我们能把沙拉放在哪里？要让人一眼看出她在吃沙拉。是的，我们开始时是让她单手拿着，为了吃不得不把手从方向盘上拿开。这太搞笑了。
She is such an amazing physical comedian. I know this footage is somewhere. I couldn't stop laughing. Ultimately, we decided that it might be like a little too unrealistic. I mean, it was so funny. And you know, by the way, she's not actually driving in these scenes.
她真是一个了不起的身体喜剧演员。我知道这段素材肯定在某处。我笑得停不下来。最终，我们觉得这可能有点太不现实了。我是说，这太搞笑了。你知道的，顺便说一句，她在这些场景里其实并没有开车。
We're hooked up to like an insert car that's pulling us because my memory is that Catherine did not drive much. She didn't. She didn't drive in Los Angeles. No, I don't think she really has a driver's license. I don't know what the system is over in the grant. No, I remember this was a whole thing. She had to get dropped off to work.
我们被连接在一辆拖着我们的插车（insert car）上，因为我的记忆是凯瑟琳不太会开车。她不会。她在洛杉矶不开车。不，我觉得她真的没有驾照。我不知道他们在格兰特那边是什么系统。不，我记得这闹得沸沸扬扬的。她必须有人开车送她上班。
Yes, they had someone drop her off. Yeah. I think for insurance reasons, they're're like we don't want this actress Who doesn't have a driver's license and who doesn't drive on the right side of the road having to drive so far out To where we would shoot. Yeah, so yes, this was quite an adventure Well, you know in the scene Nelly is distracted. She swirves and Pam's like, ah, and she kind of like pulls herself to the side. She's like, turn, there's something in your hand. Did you see it?
是的，他们让人送她来。是的。我想出于保险原因，他们会觉得我们不希望这个没有驾照、不在靠右侧道路上开车的女演员开那么远的路来到我们拍摄的地方。是的，所以这真是一场冒险。好吧，你知道在那个场景中内莉分心了。她猛地一打方向盘，帕姆惊呼了一声“啊”，她身体往旁边缩了一下。她说，转弯，你手里拿的是什么？你看到了吗？
Yes, I squeeze it. You squeeze it. Yes, I was very curious. I couldn't make out what was in your hand. So I went to the shooting draft. It says that Pam is holding a wrapped sandwich. Yes. And after Nelly's swerves, she looks down
是的，我把它捏扁了。你把它捏扁了。是的，我很好奇。我看不清你手里拿的是什么。所以我去翻了拍摄剧本。上面写着帕姆手里拿着一个用包装纸包的三明治。是的。在内莉猛打方向盘后，她低头一看
and she's gripped it in her hand and squished it. Yes. That was an extra joke, and I'm not sure it ever landed because we had the lipstick cams, we couldn't punch in on it. No, I couldn't make out. There's no punching in. What you were squishing.
她把它紧紧抓在手里，捏扁了。是的。那是一个额外的笑话，我不确定它是否达到了效果，因为我们有唇膏摄像机，我们无法做特写推镜头。不，我看不出来。没有特写推镜头。你捏的是什么。
Yes. I was curious about the best foods to eat while driving. Oh. There are a lot of opinions about this online. Can I guess one? I'm going to give you top five and one of them is kind of a category. Oh. Guess one.
是的。我对开车时吃什么食物最好很感兴趣。哦。网上对此有很多看法。我能猜一个吗？我要给你列出前五名，其中一个是某一类食物。哦。猜一个。
Burrito. Yes. That is in the category with sandwiches, wraps, bagels, burritos. Oh. Mm-hmm. Okay. French fries. Number one, on many list, French fries. I get it.
卷饼。是的。那是和三明治、卷饼、贝果、墨西哥卷饼一类的。哦。嗯哼。好吧。炸薯条。许多榜单上的第一名，炸薯条。我懂。
But what about if you want to dip your fry in ketchup? Well, that's a different thing. But a lot of people, whatever French fry, fast food, place they go to, they put the container of fries in the cup holder. Mm-hmm, mm-hmm. Yeah. Burger.
但是如果你想把薯条蘸番茄酱怎么办呢？嗯，那是另一回事了。但是很多人，无论去哪个炸薯条快餐店，他们都会把薯条盒放在杯架里。嗯哼，嗯哼。是的。汉堡。
Mm-hmm. Beef jer Burger. Mm-hmm. Beef jerky. I was surprised by this one, but then Josh told me in his 20s, whenever he went on a road trip, he made sure to bring beef jerky. Have we talked about this? I only see beef jerky as something
嗯哼。牛肉干汉堡。嗯哼。牛肉干。我对这个感到很惊讶，但后来乔希告诉我，他在二十岁时，每当去公路旅行，他一定确保带上牛肉干。我们谈过这个吗？我只把牛肉干视为那种
that goes in like your prepper backpack for the zombie apocalypse. No. I don't snack on it. I don't like it, but people road trip with it. And I guess they pack their zombie't snack on it. I don't like it, but people roadtrip with it. And I guess they pack their zombie apocalypse bag with it. Yeah.
放在僵尸末日生存背包里的东西。不。我不吃零食。我不喜欢它，但人们带着它进行公路旅行。我想他们把僵尸末日包里装满了它。不吃零食。我不喜欢它，但人们带着它进行公路旅行。我想他们把僵尸末日包里装满了它。是的。
Well, I don't see it as a roadtrip food. I see it as a survivalist food. Last one that made the top five, which I always have in my car. Right now you could go to my console. There would be one in there. Grinola bar. Grinola bar. Keep one with me. Granola bar. Granola bar. Keep one with me.
好吧，我不认为它是公路旅行食物。我认为它是生存主义者的食物。进入前五名的最后一种食物，我车里一直都有。现在你去看我的中控台。里面就会有一个。燕麦棒。燕麦棒。我身上一直备着。燕麦棒。燕麦棒。我身上一直备着。
These are good foods for while driving. A burrito? A burrito. That's like a hot mess. I guess you have to keep it right. No, I've talked to the boy. No, I've talked to the boy. No, it would be a hot mess.
这些都是开车时适合吃的食物。卷饼？卷饼。那简直是一团糟。我想你得把它拿好。不，我和那个男孩谈过。不，我和那个男孩谈过。不，那会是一团糟。
But yeah, burrito. Burrito, that's least favorite. I'd like to add one to the list. Okay, banana. Yes. Although then you're left with the peel. But that's okay. You just flop it in the floorboard and then you forget about it.
但是，好吧，卷饼。卷饼，那是最不喜欢的。我想往名单上加一个。好吧，香蕉。是的。虽然那样会留下果皮。不过没关系。你把它随手扔在脚垫上，然后就忘了它。
Then your car gets a funky smell and then you find it. Yeah. Yeah. It's happened many times. So back at the office, Oscars talking to some folks and he says to people, you guys, if Andy is related to Michelle Obama, there's a possibility that his family were slave owners.
然后你的车就会产生一股怪味，接着你才发现它。是的。是的。这发生过很多次。回到办公室，奥斯卡正在和一些人说话，他告诉大家，各位，如果安迪和米歇尔·奥巴马有亲戚关系，那他的家族很有可能是奴隶主。
Yeah, Stanley's gonna chime in here, too. Yeah, but then when we're in the car, Nelly tells Pam that she made the whole thing up. Andy isn't even related to Michelle Obama in the first place. Well, I want you to know the second driving scene started with a bit at the top that didn't make it in. Okay. I read it in the shooting draft and I made me laugh so hard.
对，斯坦利也会在这里插话。对，但后来我们在车里时，内莉告诉帕姆她完全是胡编的。安迪根本和米歇尔·奥巴马没有任何亲戚关系。好吧，我想让你们知道，第二个开车场景开头有一段没被采用的戏码。好吧。我在拍摄剧本里读到了，把我笑得前仰后合。
Ready? Here it is. Interior Pam's car, Nelly is driving. The mood is slightly somber. Pam, you can't dwell on it. Nelly. It's just what's the one thing you associate with squirrels, a quickness, an ability to scamper. They've run over a squirrel.
准备好了吗？在这里。内景，帕姆的车里，内莉在开车。气氛略显忧郁。帕姆，你不能纠结于此。内莉。你知道你把松鼠和什么联系在一起吗？敏捷，一种蹦蹦跳跳的能力。它们撞死了一只松鼠。
It says Pam nods, they drive in silence for a moment, and then that's when they get into the rest of the scene. I remember that now. You can't dwell on it. Doing these scenes with Katherine was so fun. Oh my gosh, I loved being teamed up with her. We spent a whole day on these. Gosh, she made me laugh.
上面写着帕姆点点头，他们沉默了一会儿，然后就开始了接下来的场景。我现在想起来了。你不能纠结于此。和凯瑟琳一起拍这些场景太有趣了。哦天哪，我太喜欢和她搭档了。我们为此花了一整天。天哪，她把我逗笑了。
In this scene, she goes on to explain that she made up the story about Andy and Michelle Obama as payback for him sorting her undies. This got me curious about fun British phrases, and I looked some up. I love a fun British phrase. All right, here are some fun British phrases to expand your vocabulary and sound cool. Okay. Ready? Um, bagsy.
在这个场景中，她接着解释说，她编造关于安迪和米歇尔·奥巴马的故事，是为了报复他整理她的内裤。这让我对有趣的英国俚语产生了好奇，于是我查了一些。我喜欢有趣的英国俚语。好吧，这里有一些有趣的英国俚语，可以丰富你的词汇量，让你显得很酷。好的。准备好了吗？嗯，Bagsy。
Bagsy. Yeah. If you yell bagsy, it's like calling dibs or shotgun. Okay. But if there's like, oh, someone's like, oh oh there's only one cola left back see yeah, okay got it Brawley Brawley is that when you take your bra off you're done. I'm brawley. No If it's raining you got to grab your brawley. It's short for umbrella. Oh
Bagsy。是的。如果你喊 bagsy，就像是宣示占有权或者抢占副驾驶座。好吧。但如果有人说，哦，哦，只剩下一罐可乐了，bagsy！是的，好吧，明白了。Broly。Broly 是指你把胸罩脱下来吗？你结束了。我是 broly。不。如果下雨了，你得拿上你的 broly。它是雨伞（umbrella）的简称。哦
My gosh lady what I am cream cracker. Tired. Yes. Yes. How about this? Wow, you've made a real dogs dinner out of that. Is that mean you just destroyed something? You ate so much of it. No, it kind of like a mess. Like you made a mess of it. Hot mess. Yeah, hot mess. You made a dog's dinner of that. You know what? What? I'm Hank Marvin. Means I'm starving.
天哪，女士，我累坏了。累了。是的。是的。这个怎么样？哇，你把那件事搞得一团糟（real dog's dinner）。那是说你把什么东西毁了吗？你吃了太多？不，有点像一团糟。就像你把它弄得一团糟。一团糟。是的，一团糟。你把那件事搞得像一团糟。你知道吗？什么？我是 Hank Marvin。意思是饿了。
I'm a starving Marvin. I'm Hank Marvin. Hank Marvin. Yeah. You know what? Don't get shirty with me, mister. Oh, is that Snippy? Yeah, someone who's like short tempered.
我饿得要命。我是 Hank Marvin。Hank Marvin。是的。你知道吗，先生，别跟我发脾气（don't get shirty）。哦，那是说人尖酸刻薄吗？是的，指脾气暴躁的人。
Snippy, yeah. Don't get shirty with me. Don't get it twisted and get shirty with me. And how about this? Excuse me, I need to go spend a penny. Is that pee? Yes! This is a polite way of saying you have to go to the bathroom because I guess back in the day,
尖酸刻薄，是的。别跟我发脾气。别搞错状况跟我发脾气。还有这个呢？对不起，我得去上个厕所（spend a penny）。那是小便吗？是的！这是一种礼貌的说法，表示你得去洗手间，因为我想在过去，
the women's restroom cost a penny! I've got to go spend a penny. Yeah. Well, you know, my friend, Mika, is from Australia. the day the women's restroom cost a penny. I've got to go spend a penny. Yeah. Well, you know, my friend, Mika, is from Australia. And he told me that his mom, one time, there was someone they were talking about, and his mom was like, oh, she's a real see you next Tuesday.
女厕所要花一便士！我得去上个厕所。是的。好吧，你知道的，我的朋友米卡来自澳大利亚。过去女厕所要花一便士。我得去上个厕所。是的。好吧，你知道的，我的朋友米卡来自澳大利亚。他告诉我，有一次他妈妈在谈论某个人，他妈妈就说，哦，她真是个老母狗（see you next Tuesday）。
What's a see you next Tuesday? What is it? It's, what is it? It's a see, next Tuesday. I'm so sorry. I just got it. I just got it. Sam's laughing.
什么是 see you next Tuesday？是什么？这是，是什么？这是一个，下周二见。我很抱歉。我刚刚反应过来。我刚刚反应过来。萨姆在笑。
He's trying to help me. So yeah. See you next Tuesday. You don't want to be a CU next Tuesday. You sure don't. Oh my gosh. If you get too surety, you're going to become a CNX Tuesday. Oh, fun phrases. Faces. I guess something happens to Pam's car and she has to get the tire changed. Yeah, I guess
他试图帮我。所以是的。下周二见。你可不想当个老母狗。你绝对不想。哦天哪。如果你脾气太暴躁，你就会变成一个老母狗。哦，有趣的俚语。面孔。我想帕姆的车出了点故障，她得换轮胎。是的，我想
Nelly maybe has run over something. Probably run over something. Pam is going to have a talking head. She's pretty tickled by Nelly. She says she's fearless and almost sort of fun. And while Pam is saying this, Nelly is pretending to be hitting the mechanic from behind Pam Chuckles. This is hilarious. She's loving it. This is their Thelma and Louise moment.
内莉可能轧到什么东西了。可能轧到什么东西了。帕姆有一个单独采访镜头。她对内莉赞赏有加。她说内莉无所畏惧，甚至有点有趣。就在帕姆说这话的时候，内莉在帕姆身后假装要打那个机修工。帕姆咯咯笑了起来。这太搞笑了。她很喜欢。这是他们的《末路狂花》时刻。
You know, we had a fan catch from Natalia M. in Toronto, Canada who said, I'm thinking back to season three, women's appreciation when Pam changes the tire on Meredith's car. Oh yeah, but this time she needed help. Yeah. I guess maybe Nelly did more damage. Yeah. Pam did need some help. Also, just if you have AAA, you know, Pam could have called, but maybe Meredith didn't have it, so Pam had to change the tire. I can change a tire, can you? Yes.
你知道的，我们收到了来自加拿大多伦多的娜塔莉亚·M的粉丝来信，她说：“我想到了第三季的‘女性赞赏日’，当时帕姆给梅雷迪思的车换轮胎。”哦对，但这次她需要帮助。是的。我猜内莉可能造成了更大的破坏。是的。帕姆确实需要一些帮助。另外，如果你有 AAA（美国汽车协会），你知道的，帕姆本可以打电话，但也许梅雷迪思没有，所以帕姆不得不换轮胎。我会换轮胎，你会吗？是的。
And I have. Yeah. My dad made sure. Me too. And you got to do the nuts and a star. Yeah. You don't do them in a circle. That's the best way to get them tight, tighten them in a star pattern.
我换过。是的。我爸爸确保我学会了。我也是。你得按星形顺序拧螺母。是的。你不能按圆圈顺序。那是把它拧紧的最佳方法，按星形图案拧紧。
My dad also made sure I had a socket wrench set in my car. And of course, jumper cables. Yes. All the things. All the things. Well, it's time for a get-to-know-your-casting crew from the call she. Okay. We have Kim Ferry from the Hair and Makeup Department. Three things you didn't know about Kim Ferry.
我爸爸还确保我的车里有一套套筒扳手。当然，还有搭电线。是的。所有的东西。所有的东西。好吧，是时候进行“了解你的演职人员”环节了，出场的是凯姆·费里。好吧。我们有美发化妆部的凯姆·费里。关于凯姆·费里你不知道的三件事。
Kim knows sign language. The prettiest place she has ever been is Monaco. Her favorite superhero is Wonder Woman, and she once worked in the games department at Six Flags Great America. Kim misses family vacations with her parents, and she was Miss Gurney Illinois in 1986. Wow! So lovely. I know, I love these. I think we might need to do it, get to know your office ladies, crew. Yes! And answer these questions, we'll send out an email with the questions to our group.
凯姆会手语。她去过最美丽的地方是摩纳哥。她最喜欢的超级英雄是神奇女侠，她曾在六旗美利坚乐园的游戏部门工作过。凯姆怀念和父母一起的家庭旅行，她还是1986年伊利诺伊州吉尔尼小姐。哇！太棒了。我知道，我喜欢这些。我想我们可能需要做一个“了解你的办公室职员”演职人员版。是的！并回答这些问题，我们会把带有问题的文件发给我们的团队。
I like these group of questions. I don't know who came up with them, but I really like them. Andy is going to come into the bullpen now, and his employees are all gathered around talking, and he's like, hey, get back to work. Yeah, yeah. And Oscar tells Andi, he might wanna be nice to people today because his relation to Michelle Obama carries some implications, some negative connotations.
我喜欢这组问题。我不知道是谁想出来的，但我真的很喜欢。安迪现在要走进员工办公区了，他的员工们都聚在一起聊天，他说，嘿，回去工作吧。对，对。奥斯卡告诉安迪，他今天最好对大家客气点，因为他与米歇尔·奥巴马的关系带有某种暗示，某种负面含义。
Then he says, you know, this means that you most likely have slave owners in your family lineage. And he's like, who else thinks this is the case? Everyone agrees. And this is when we have Darrell's talking head that he filmed earlier when he was batching. Yeah. That person has really gotten him or herself into quite a predicament.
然后他说，你知道的，这意味着你的家族谱系里极有可能有奴隶主。安迪问，还有谁认为会是这样？大家都表示赞同。然后就是达里尔之前做批量处理时拍摄的单独采访画面。是的。那家伙真的是把自己陷入了一个相当尴尬的境地。
I really enjoyed that call back. I did too. That was really funny. I did too. And he is now going to call his mom. I really enjoyed that call back. I did too. That was really fun. I did too. Andy is now gonna call his mom. He goes to voicemail, but he really needs to know. He just has a quick question about America's national shame. Yeah.
我真的很喜欢那个回忆梗。我也是。那个真的很好笑。我也是。他现在要给他妈妈打电话了。我真的很喜欢那个回忆梗。我也是。那真的很有趣。我也是。安迪现在要给他妈妈打电话了。他打到了语音信箱，但他真的很想知道。他只是有个关于美国国耻的小问题。对。
Just quickly, I need to ask you some questions. Meanwhile, Darrell comes in to discuss business. Yes, he's trying to get work done. And Andy is too distracted, and Darrell is annoyed. He has worked on this whole report, and Andy has not paid any attention to it. This is going to feed into a later storyline. That's right, of Darrell's frustration at the company. After the scene, there was one between Oscar and Angela over and accounting.
简单说一下，我需要问你几个问题。与此同时，达瑞尔进来谈论公事。对，他想把工作做完。而安迪太分心了，达瑞尔很不爽。他做了整份报告，而安迪一点也没关注。这会为后面的剧情做铺垫。没错，就是达瑞尔对公司感到沮丧。这场戏之后，奥斯卡和安吉拉之间有一场关于会计的戏。
Oh, it was in the shooting draft, it's indelated scenes. Angela's gonna notice Oscar's tie. I want you to hear it. Oscar, is that a Paul Smith tie? The Senator loves them. Oh, does he? Yeah, they're really expensive. Really?
哦，那是在拍摄剧本里，是被删减的片段。安吉拉会注意到奥斯卡的领带。我想让你们听听。奥斯卡，那是保罗·史密斯（Paul Smith）的领带吗？参议员很喜欢这个牌子。哦，是吗？对，它们真的很贵。真的吗？
Well, this was a gift from my wealthy aunt, that fire... Oh. Oh! Oscar is wearing a tie that just happens to be one of the senator's favorites. Mm-hmm. Lucky him, he has a wealthy aunt, doubt fire. Yeah. I do love a Paul Smith tie.. Just going to say, you in the
嗯，这是我富有的姑姑送的礼物，那个火灾……哦。哦！奥斯卡戴的领带刚好是参议员最喜欢的款式之一。嗯哼。他真幸运，有个富有的姑姑，道特·法尔（doubt fire）。对。我很喜欢保罗·史密斯的领带……我只想说，在……
simulator, it is a sharp looking tie. So you know, throughout this episode, Dwight has been teaching Aaron Dothraki. Yes. And now they're going to take it to the bullpen, walking around, pointing to things, does Aaron know what it is? You know, Reinde did a couple of interviews where he said that he absolutely loved doing this storyline. And I guess there were even more scenes that got cut. He said he was most upset that there was a talking head where he is shirtless and he's speaking to Throcky.
模拟器里，这领带看起来真精神。你们知道吗，在这集里，德怀特一直在教艾琳多斯拉克语。对。现在他们要去办公大楼的开放办公区了，走来走去，指着各种东西，艾琳知道那是什么吗？你知道的，雷恩（Rainn）做过几次采访，他说他绝对超级喜欢拍这条故事线。我猜还有更多的镜头被剪掉了。他说他最难过的是有一个单人访谈镜头，里面他光着膀子，然后用多斯拉克语说话。
And it was cut. He was very disappointed. Yes, they're in the deleted scenes. I didn't include them in my sharing today because it's a site gag. So one, you can't see. Angela, you are learning that we're on listen, it's not going to last long. But he's shirtless with no explanation. And then he's got a talking head in Dothraki, which there are subtitles that you can't read. Yes.
结果被剪掉了。他非常失望。对，它们在删减片段里。我今天分享的时候没把它们放进去，因为那是个视觉笑话。所以一呢，你看不到。安吉拉，你正在学我们说话，听着，这不会持续太久的。但他光着膀子却没有解释。然后他还有一个多斯拉克语的单人访谈，里面有你看不懂的字幕。对。
I would say I think Reen did a very good job. This is probably why she sat it and made me. Yeah. Because he learned a whole talking head in Dothraki. But yeah, if you guys want to check him out, they're on the DVDs. Well, as they move through the office, speaking Dothraki, Pete says hi in Aaron, responds in Dothraki.
我想说，雷恩做得真的很好。这可能就是为什么她坐着让我演。对。因为他整段单人访谈都用多斯拉克语背下来了。但是，嘿，如果你们想看看，它们都在DVD里。好吧，当他们在办公室里走动，说着多斯拉克语时，皮特说了句你好，艾琳用多斯拉克语回应。
And he's kind of like, I'm sorry. He's not really sure what's happening. She also tries to speak Dothraki. And he's kind of like, I'm sorry, like he's not really sure what's happening. She also tries to speak Dothraki to Andy. Yes. He's asking if anyone's turned in their progress reports. And then he's like, what are you doing? Why would you learn a made up language from a television show?
然后他有点像，抱歉。他不太确定发生了什么。她还试图说多斯拉克语。然后他有点像，抱歉，就好像他不太确定发生了什么。她还试图对安迪说多斯拉克语。对。他问有没有人交进度报告。然后他就像，你在干嘛？为什么你要从电视剧里学一门虚构的语言？
And then she's like, Dwight, why didn't you tell me this was made up? And he says, listen, people laughed at clingingon at first and now you can major in it. I had to know. Can you? Sort of. Yes. This is Dwight.
然后她说，德怀特，你为什么不告诉我这是虚构的？他说，听着，人们一开始嘲笑克林贡语，现在你都可以把它当专业来学了。我得知道。可以吗？算是吧。对。这就是德怀特。
There's always a half truth. You can study Klingon and Dothraki in college as part of linguistics courses. In fact, I found out that Klingon is the most widely spoken fictional language. I do not doubt that. That fandom is deep and strong. The University of Texas at Austin offers a course where you study Klingon. The University of Alaska Fairbanks has a course called Elfish, Klingon, and a Throcky course in development. Our son Jack learned, learned Elfish. What is Elfish for? Is that Lord of the Rings?
总会有半真半假的话。你可以在大学里把克林贡语和多斯拉克语当作语言学课程的一部分来研究。事实上，我发现克林贡语是使用最广泛的虚构语言。对此我毫不怀疑。那个粉丝群体深厚且强大。德克萨斯大学奥斯汀分校开设了一门课程，你可以去学习克林贡语。阿拉斯加大学费尔班克斯分校有一门叫做精灵语、克林贡语的课程，还有一门多斯拉克语课程正在开发中。我们的儿子杰克学过……学过精灵语。精灵语是用来干嘛的？那是《指环王》里的吗？
Yes. Oh. So this is a whole thing, and I read about it, and now I didn't write down the name of it, but this idea of creating language, the creation of language. When you study these fictional languages, it's part of just understanding the creation of language, when you study these fictional languages, it's part of just understanding
对。哦。所以这是一整套东西，我读过关于它的文章，现在我没写下它的名字，但这种创造语言的想法，语言的创造。当你研究这些虚构语言时，它只是理解语言创造的一部分，当你研究这些虚构语言时，它只是理解
the creation of language in general. This is what David talks about in the Wired magazine interview that I'm going to put in stories. Well, I was also fascinated to find out that there is something called the Klingon Language Institute. It was founded in 1992 with quote, the mission of bringing together individuals interested in the study of Klingon linguistics and culture. And as a side note, while reviewing like interesting college
广义上的语言创造。这就是大卫在《连线》杂志采访中谈到的内容，我会把它发到快拍里。嗯，我也很着迷地发现，有一个叫作克林贡语研究所（Klingon Language Institute）的组织。它成立于1992年，用他们的话说，“宗旨是将对克林贡语言学和文化研究感兴趣的个人聚集在一起”。顺便提一下，在回顾一些有趣的大学
courses that are available, there is a course at Columbia College, Chicago, and the University of Baltimore called zombies in popular media. You would like that. Sign me up. Mm-hmm. Fascinated by zombie culture, personally. What is the culture? There is no culture. They eat people. They then moan about. There are so many other person. Okay. There are so many things and debates about what zombies can do and not do. And different iterations. Don't get me started on what happened
可选课程时，芝加哥哥伦比亚学院和巴尔的摩大学有一门名为“流行文化中的僵尸”的课程。你会喜欢这个的。算我一个。嗯哼。我个人对僵尸文化很着迷。有什么文化？根本没有文化。他们吃人。然后他们发出呻吟。还有那么多其他的人。好吧。关于僵尸能做什么和不能做什么，有太多的事情和争论了。还有不同的版本。别让我开始抱怨
when they remade the dawn of the dead movies and the zombies started moving fast. Because in the past, zombies only moved slow. They moved slow. They moved slow. Like that's one of the things about them that is so scary is that like, they can't run fast at you, but they never stop.
当他们重拍《活死人黎明》电影，僵尸开始快速移动时发生的事情了。因为在过去，僵尸总是走得很慢。它们走得很慢。它们走得很慢。就像那是它们可怕的地方之一，就是它们不能向你飞奔而来，但它们永不停歇。
Like they will slowly gain ground and then they kind of back you into a corner. You know what I'm saying? I don't, that's what's scary about them. But then all of a sudden in the new movies, they're speedy fast moving real quick. Yeah, scaryness. I'm sure there were Reddit threads abuzz about the fast versus slow movie.
就像它们会慢慢逼近，然后把你逼进死角。你知道我在说什么吗？我不，这就是它们可怕的地方。但突然间，在新电影里，它们变得飞快，移动得非常快。是的，太吓人了。我确信红迪网（Reddit）上一定有很多关于快僵尸与慢僵尸的热议帖子。
The zombie, the zombie Reddit threads. And I would think that that would be part of this college course. Jenna, you should take it. I wonder if there's an online version. I am serious. You should take it. Would you take a dothraki one? Like to learn to speak dothraki. I don't know. I mean, it'd be a good party trick, I guess. Yeah. Anyway, something to think about with all our extra time that we have. I know. I just think about there's so many languages I want to learn that are spoken in countries that, you know, I would be actually...
僵尸，僵尸红迪网帖子。我想这也是这门大学课程的一部分吧。珍娜，你应该去上。我想知道有没有在线版。我是认真的。你应该去上。你会上多斯拉克语的课吗？比如学说多斯拉克语。我不知道。我是说，这大概会是个不错的派对绝活吧。对。不管怎样，在我们所有的空闲时间里，这也是个可以考虑的事情。我知道。我只是觉得有好多我想学的语言，它们都在那些……你知道的，我实际上会……
You already speak three languages, Angela. I do, but why not go back and learn more, like be truly proficient in Spanish or something? Yeah, I wish I spoke Spanish. You can. I speak French when I'm angry, and that's it. Oh, angry French. Where are we? Oh, you know where we should go?
你已经会说三种语言了，安吉拉。我会，但为什么不回去学更多，比如真正精通西班牙语什么的？对，我希望我会说西班牙语。你可以的。我生气的时候会说法语，就这句。哦，生气的法语。我们到哪儿了？哦，你知道我们应该去哪儿吗？
We should go back on the road with Pam and Nelly. Okay. Because they are bonding about Pam's murals. Pam painted Angela's nursery? That was a bond show. I was not expecting. Shut the front door. Yeah.
我们应该和帕姆还有内莉一起重上路途。好吧。因为她们因为帕姆的壁画而建立了感情。帕姆画了安吉拉的婴儿房？那真是一段感情纽带。我完全没想到。惊掉下巴。对。
I cannot believe Angela trusted Pam to paint her baby nursery. I can't believe Angela let Pam in her home. Well, there's that. We learned that she did Angela's nursery, and you know, I guess there were a bunch of animals, but they all had to be fully clothed, like the lion was in a tuxedo.
我真不敢相信安吉拉会信任帕姆去画她宝宝的婴儿房。我不敢相信安吉拉会让帕姆进她家。嗯，还有这个。我们得知她画了安吉拉的婴儿房，而且你知道的，我猜有一堆动物，但它们都必须穿戴整齐，比如狮子穿着燕尾服。
Well, you have something in common with Angela Martin is which is that you love pictures of animals and little outfits, Angie. Little hats and vests and things. You know, I hear you. I mean, a cowboy hamster will make your day. Get out. With a little leather vest. If you could get a mean, a cowboy hamster will make your day. Get out. With a little leather vest.
好吧，你和安吉拉·马丁有一个共同点，那就是你喜欢动物穿着小衣服的照片，安吉吉。小帽子、背心之类的。你知道的，我懂你。我是说，牛仔仓鼠会让你的一整天都变美好。滚开。穿着一件小皮背心。如果你能弄到……牛仔仓鼠会让你的一整天都变美好。滚开。穿着一件小皮背心。
If you could get a little vest on a hamster, I would lose my mind. Nelly is going to get a text while she is driving Pam around. So Pam's like, up about, I'll read it for you. And it is a new project from Andy. He would like her to make a family tree for everyone in the office. And he's particularly interested in the dirt. Dig up dirt. So Nellie's
如果你能给仓鼠穿上一件小背心，我会疯掉的。内莉在载着帕姆兜风时收到了一条短信。所以帕姆就说，关于……我来帮你读。这是安迪的一个新项目。他想让她为办公室里的每个人做一个家谱。他尤其对黑历史感兴趣。挖掘黑历史。所以内莉
like we have to come up with a bunch of lies. Yeah, she wants to just mess with him. Pam is going to tell her to say that Jim is related to Richard Nixon. She says it's an inside joke. Yeah, he looks very nixiny when he wakes up. And this is when Pam shares that she does feel like there's something Jim is not telling her. Yeah. Yeah. And Nelly's like, oh no, and a fair and Pam's like, no, no, no. He loves me way too much for that. There was a whole old version of this scene. It was much bigger, much longer. Nelly and Pam stop on the side of the road. They're at a park. They sit on a bench.
就说我们必须编造一堆谎言。对，她只想捉弄他。帕姆要她说是吉姆和理查德·尼克森有亲戚关系。她说这只是个内部笑话。对，他醒来的时候看起来非常像尼克森。这就是帕姆分享她确实觉得吉姆有什么事瞒着她的时刻。对。对。然后内莉说，哦不，有外遇吗？帕姆说，不，不，不。他太爱我了，不会这样的。这个场景原本有一个旧版本。规模更大，长得多。内莉和帕姆把车停在路边。她们在一个公园里。她们坐在长椅上。
They're having a snack. And I thought we should hear the full extended scene. I remember shooting it. Sometimes when I walk by his desk, he closes his browser window really fast. Who happens? The men of his or creaches. I've been assured they may do it. I don't think it's porn. He's also been taking these phone calls. He won't say with who. Deela, Drock Deela. And he's got a bad. No. But he's left the office for a couple of lunches, too.
她们在吃零食。我觉得我们应该听听完整的加长版场景。我记得当时拍过。有时我路过他的桌子时，他会把浏览器窗口关得特别快。谁会这样？他的那些男人们。我向他们保证过他们可以这么做。我不觉得那是色情片。他还经常接电话。他不说跟谁打的。狄拉，德罗克·狄拉。他还带了个包。不对。但他也有好几次午餐时间不在办公室。
Oh, no. This is worse. He's having an affair. No, that's not it. Well, the signs are all pretty classic, won't they? Oh my God. Could you be having an affair? Well, the signs are all pretty classic, aren't they? Oh my God, could you be having enough fare? Nope.
哦，不。这更糟了。他在搞外遇。不，不是这样的。好吧，这些迹象都很经典，不是吗？哦天哪。你该不会在搞外遇吧？好吧，这些迹象都很经典，不是吗？哦天哪，你该不会在搞外遇吧？才没有。
Thanks for talking it through though. No, you can't be completely sure. I can. Well, no, I just mean there's always a possibility to do this. Seriously, there isn't. I know, I sound like one of those sad, diluded women, but Jim will never cheat on me. Other bad stuff could happen to us, but it won't be that. How can you know that?
不过还是谢谢你陪我聊这些。不，你不能完全确定。我可以。好吧，不，我的意思是凡事总有可能。说真的，不可能。我知道，我听起来像那些可悲的、受蒙蔽的女人，但吉姆绝对不会对我不忠。我们身上可能会发生其他糟糕的事情，但绝对不会是这个。你怎么能这么确定？
Because he just loves me too much. You're a coquil little thing on your head. Angela, I am really glad that you played that clip. For all the people who hate on Pam for not being quote unquote supportive of Jim's new job, listen to what he has been doing to her, the stress that he has put her under with all the sneaky phone calls and the lunches and the lying he's a liar. He has been lying to her for weeks. Yes, weeks. And then by the way, at the end of this episode when she finds everything out, she still gives him a hug. She's still like, I guess,
因为他太爱我了。你头上顶着个古怪的小东西。安吉拉，我真的很高兴你放了这段剪辑。对于所有讨厌帕姆不支持吉姆新工作的人，听听他一直在对她做的事吧，他那些鬼鬼祟祟的电话、午餐和谎言给她带来了多大的压力，他是个骗子。他已经对她撒谎好几周了。是的，好几周。然后顺便说一下，在这集结尾，当她发现所有事情后，她依然给了他一个拥抱。她仍然表现得像，好吧，我想，
okay, we're going to do it. But this whole dream job of gyms has started with a betrayal. whole dream job of gyms has started with a betrayal. And he's totally unaware of it too. Like he doesn't even apologize for betraying her. He doesn't say I should have never. He doesn't get it. There is a scene in deleted scenes. Again, it's a sight keg. Okay.
我们要这么做。但吉姆的这个梦想工作是从背叛开始的。吉姆的整个梦想工作是从背叛开始的。而且他对此也完全没有察觉。就像他甚至没有为背叛她而道歉。他没有说“我不该这么做”。他根本不明白。被删减的片段里有一个场景。同样，这也是个视觉笑话。好吧。
So I'm gonna describe it. Jim is looking at office space rentals on his computer screen and the camera catches it. And then he looks over his shoulder and he's busted and quickly goes to the screen saver image that says Dundermifflin. So camera is catching it. And Jim is going to have a moment with Brian who works for the documentary crew and I'm going to play it for you in a bit. I mean I'm silent because I just don't understand
所以我要描述一下。吉姆正在电脑屏幕上查看办公室租赁空间，镜头刚好拍到了。然后他转头看了一下肩膀，结果被抓包了，于是迅速切换到写着“邓德米夫林”的屏幕保护程序图片。所以镜头拍到了这一幕。吉姆接下来要和为纪录片摄制组工作的布莱恩谈一谈，我一会儿放给你们听。我是说我很安静，因为我只是不明白
why there is not more sympathy for Pam's position in this. Well, I think people are hearing it now. They're seeing a bigger more fleshed out storyline, so I think they're gonna hear it. Okay. Well listen, should we go to the conference room because Andy's gonna start telling people about their family histories? Now these family histories were all made up by Nelly and Pam. Mm-hmm. So Phyllis is great great grandmother spread cholera. Yeah, Kevin is related to John Wayne Gacy and John Wayne Bobbitt not John Wayne though and not Dwayne Johnson either. Mm- either. Jim is related to Richard Dixon. Jim is confused. Yeah. He has a talking head.
为什么大家对帕姆在这件事上的处境没有更多的同情呢。嗯，我觉得大家现在听到了。他们看到了一个更大、更丰满的剧情线，所以我觉得他们会听进去的。好吧。听着，我们要不要去会议室，因为安吉拉（应为安迪）要开始跟大伙讲他们的家族史了？现在这些家族史全都是由内莉和帕姆胡编乱造的。嗯哼。所以菲莉丝的高曾祖母传播了霍乱。对，凯文和约翰·韦恩·盖西以及约翰·韦恩·鲍比特有亲戚关系，不过不是约翰·韦恩本人，也不是道恩·强森。也不是。吉姆和理查德·尼克森有亲戚关系。吉姆很困惑。对。他有一个单人访谈镜头。
Pam always said he looks like Nixon. That's not true, right? And then he kind of holds a photo up and he's like, oh gosh, he sees it. At this point, Andy gets a phone call from his mom. And guess what? His family did not own slaves. They transported slaves. Yeah. Fan question from Abby W. in Houston, Texas. Why would Andy's mom know so much
帕姆总说他长得像尼克森。这不是真的，对吧？然后他举起一张照片，心想，哦天哪，他看出来了。就在这时，安迪接到了他妈妈的打来的电话。你猜怎么着？他的家族没有拥有过奴隶。他们运送奴隶。对。来自德克萨斯州休斯顿的艾比·W.的粉丝提问。为什么安迪的妈妈会知道这么多
about the Bernard family history? It's not even her blood relatives. Oh, Abby, I believe it. I feel like the mom's hold all the info, right? They're historians, right? I believed this. Yeah. That Andy's mom probably took a great interest in the Bernard family. Yeah. And I don't know, don't you feel like it's the moms
关于伯纳德家族历史的事？那甚至都不是她有血缘关系的亲戚。哦，艾比，我相信。我觉得妈妈们掌握了所有的信息，对吧？她们是历史学家，对吧？我相信这一点。对。安迪的妈妈可能对伯纳德家族表现出了极大的兴趣。对。而且我不知道，难道你不觉得是妈妈们
who get all the family dirt too? They ask the question. They ask the questions. I think they also write it down. Right. They keep a record. I will say though, I feel like every family has a one person that's very curious.
掌握了所有的家族黑历史吗？她们会问问题。她们会问问题。我觉得她们还会把它写下来。对。她们会做记录。不过我要说的是，我觉得每个家族都有一个好奇心特别重的人。
And on my dad's side of the family, it was my grandmother. She did all this research. But on my mom's side of the family, it's my uncle Jack, her brother. Yeah, I'll say on my dad's side of the family, his brother Don, did a fully extensive genealogy on the Fisher side of the family. You need one. You need one person in your family.
在我爸爸这边，是我奶奶。她做了所有的这些研究。但在我妈妈那边，是我舅舅杰克，她的哥哥。对，我要说在我爸爸那边，他的哥哥唐，对费舍尔家族的族谱进行了非常详尽的研究。你需要一个人。你家族里需要这样一个人。
There's always one person. So I guess for the Bernard's, it's Andy's mom. We also got a fan question from Martha B. in Malta, who would love to be mentioned as our first Malta's question. Oh! That's lots of love from Europe, hi Martha. Hi Martha from Malta? Martha asks, are you ladies related to anyone famous
总会有这样一个人。所以我想对伯纳德家族来说，这个人就是安迪的妈妈。我们还收到了来自马耳他的玛莎·B.的粉丝提问，她很想被提及为我们首个来自马耳他的提问者。哦！来自欧洲满满的爱，嗨，玛莎。嗨，来自马耳他的玛莎？玛莎问，你们女士和什么名人有亲戚关系吗
or do you ever get told you look like someone famous? I was recently told I look like Brie Larson. Oh, I was like, I love it. That's a compliment. It is, but I don't think we have anyone famous in our family that I know of. You know, I have been told that I could play Laura Dern's sister. You could.
或者你们有没有被说过长得像哪个名人？我最近被说长得像布丽·拉尔森（Brie Larson）。哦，我当时想，我喜欢。这是个夸奖。确实是，不过据我所知，我们家没有什么名人。你知道的，我曾被人说过我可以演劳拉·德恩（Laura Dern）的妹妹。你确实可以。
That there's a similarity in our faces. You sure could. I would be her very short sister from the short side of the family. Yeah. She's tall. Mm-hmm. I would love to be that tall. Well, thank you, Martha, for your question.
我们的脸有相似之处。你绝对可以。我会成为她个子非常矮的妹妹，来自家族里个子矮的那支。对。她很高。嗯哼。我好想长那么高啊。好吧，谢谢玛莎的提问。
Yes. From Malta. Darryl is going to enter Andy's office, and again, Andy is not giving Darryl's report any attention. No, he's not respecting any of the work Darryl's done. Yeah, in fact, he's using it as a coaster. So Darryl says, I need to go for a walk. Yeah.
是的。来自马耳他。达瑞尔要走进安迪的办公室了，而且安迪又一次完全没有关注达瑞尔的报告。不，他根本不尊重达瑞尔做过的任何工作。对，事实上，他把它当杯垫用了。所以达瑞尔说，我要出去走走。对。
Jim notices that Darryl is not in a great mood and kind of follows him out. So Jim's going to go to the Fakie staircase in the warehouse and check on Darryl. Darryl's like, I am done. Yeah. You know what? This might be a better title, but the better the titles, the stupider the job gets. Jim is now gonna hypothetically offer Darryl a job doing sports marketing in Philly. Okay, hold on a second. Did Jim ask his business partner if it was okay to start hiring people?
吉姆注意到达瑞尔心情不太好，就一路跟着他出来了。所以吉姆要走到仓库的假楼梯那里去看看达瑞尔。达瑞尔说，我不干了。对。你知道吗？这或许是个更好的头衔，但是头衔越好，工作就越蠢。吉姆现在要假设性地为达瑞尔提供一份在费城做体育营销的工作。等等，等一下。吉姆有没有问过他的合伙人，开始雇人是不是可以的？
Does Jim just make giant life decisions and business decisions without consulting his partners? Jim, other people live in the world. Okay? You have a life, you have a business partner, Jim, other people live in the world. Okay. You have a wife. You have a business partner. You're just going to call them up and be like, Hey, guess what?
难道吉姆做重大的生活决定和商业决定都不用跟合伙人商量的吗？吉姆，其他人也生活在这个世界上。好吗？你有人生，你有商业合伙人，吉姆，其他人也生活在这个世界上。好吗？你有妻子。你有商业合伙人。你就要打电话给他们说，嘿，你猜怎么着？
I know we don't have an office space yet, but I've hired an employee. Well, listen, Darryl's like, this isn't real, right? And Jim's like, no, it's happening. It really is, but we just got to keep it between us for now. And then Darryl hits Jim with the truth bomb and he says, hey, it's not real until your wife is on board. Mm-hmm, what?
我知道我们还没租到办公空间，但我已经雇了一个员工。好吧，听着，达瑞尔觉得，这不是真的，对吧？吉姆说，不，这是真的。千真万确，但我们目前得对其他人保密。然后达瑞尔给吉姆抛下了一颗真相炸弹，他说，嘿，在你妻子同意之前，这都不是真的。嗯哼，什么？
Jim's like, hadn't thought of that. I was just gonna have a job in Philly and just, I don't know, tell Pam I was going to the doctor every day. Well, Jim is gonna have a talking head now that would have come here, its indelated scenes. And Brian, the boom operator, is going to call him out. Let's hear it. Yes, Pam and I did decide together that I would not take the job, so thank you, Brian, for reminding me. This is another moment where we're very aware that there's been a documentary crew this whole time and they've seen everything.
吉姆心想：没想过这出。我本来打算在费城找个工作，然后就，我不知道，每天跟帕姆说我去医院看病。好吧，吉姆接下来有一个单人访谈镜头，本该出现在被删减片段里。而负责收音的布莱恩要把他的台词喊出来。我们听听看。对，帕姆和我确实一起决定了我不会接受这份工作，所以谢谢你，布莱恩，提醒了我。这是另一个让我们深刻意识到这里一直有个纪录片摄制组而且他们目睹了一切的时刻。
Well, also at this moment, Nelly and Pam are going to get back to the office. Nelly drives Pam's car into a hedge. To do this stunt, they put these pads behind the greenery and we put the car neutral and a group of guys actually just pushed us into the fence. Oh. They did not make catwalk drive into a fence. That's a lot less exciting. Yes. Just a few guys rolled you into the hedge. And this is when Nellie and Pam go into the warehouse and Nellie says, what do you think about putting a mural here?
嗯，也在这个时候，内莉和帕姆要回办公室了。内莉把帕姆的车开进了树篱里。为了完成这个特技，他们在绿化带后面放了这些软垫，然后我们把车挂空挡，一群小伙子真的直接把我们推到了栅栏里。哦。他们才没有让凯特沃克（Catwalk）开车撞进栅栏里呢。那可没那么刺激。对。只是几个小伙子把你们推进了树篱。接着就是内莉和帕姆走进仓库，内莉说，你觉得在这里画一幅壁画怎么样？
And I want you to do it. Pam is so excited. This was part of my storyline pitch that Pam's gonna become a muralist. I was very excited about it. But then this is also where Pam finally gets the news. Yes, Jim is now, I guess, emboldened by Darryl to be forthright, maybe because Brian called him out on it too, we find out.
而且我想让你来画。帕姆兴奋极了。这是我关于帕姆成为壁画家这一剧情构想的一部分。我当时超级兴奋。但这也是帕姆终于得知真相的时刻。对。吉姆现在，我猜在达瑞尔的鼓舞下，决定坦诚相待了，也许也是因为布莱恩当面点破了他，我们发现。
Yeah. He says he'd like to talk to her for a second. We kind of talked about this. I think we know my feelings. Jim's like, what was I worried about? She's the best! There's layers here, lady. Jim is instantly relieved. Pam is still filling unsettled. As she should. And this was, by the way, all of this is what we talked about in our pitch meetings about how let's expose some of the immaturities in Jimin Pams' relationship, some ways where maybe they aren't as good of communicators as we think. Well, this is also the thing that the writers struggled with, right, for Jimin Pams to have conflict,
对。他说他想跟她谈一谈。我们之前讨论过这个。我想我们都知道我的感受。吉姆心想：我之前担心什么呢？她最棒了！这里面有层层隐情啊，各位。吉姆瞬间如释重负。帕姆仍然觉得心里不踏实。她本该如此。顺便说一下，所有这些，正是我们在提案会议上讨论的内容，关于如何暴露吉姆和帕姆关系中的一些不成熟之处，一些可能表明他们在沟通上并没有我们想象得那么好的地方。嗯，这也是编剧们一直在纠结的事情，对吧，要让吉姆和帕姆之间产生冲突，
but it wasn't breakup conflict, it was like passive conflict. It wasn't a fair conflict. Yeah. And John and I were really excited about this because we thought, this is the stuff that real marriages go through. Yeah. This is the clunky kind of stuff that isn't like,
但这不是那种要分手的冲突，而是那种消极的冲突。不是那种外遇冲突。对。乔恩和我对此真的超级兴奋，因为我们觉得，这才是真正婚姻所经历的事情。对。这种笨拙的事情，不像是，
I'm cheating on you. It's career, it's kids, it's making a mortgage, it's all of those things. Communication. Yeah. Well, the episode is gonna end on a sweet note, I think. Everyone's leaving for the day. And Pete says goodbye to Aaron and Dothraki.
我在背叛你。这是关于事业、孩子、还房贷，所有这些事情。沟通。对。好吧，这一集将以一个温馨的基调结束，我想是的。大家都要下班了。皮特向艾琳用多斯拉克语道别。
Yeah. He didn't know what it was earlier. He was confused. Yeah. But he's so delighted by her, he went and learned a little phrase so he could say goodbye to her. And then Andy says, you know what, I like that guy. We should set him up with Meredith.
对。他之前还不知道那是什么。他当时很困惑。对。但他对她太喜爱了，所以特意去学了一个小短语，这样他就能跟她道别了。然后安迪说，你知道吗，我挺喜欢那小伙子的。我们应该把他和梅雷迪思凑成一对。
I am crushing on Pete. In this episode, I totally see why he was named one of our pop culture treasures of the week. Yeah, he's a sweetie pie, and you can't help but root for him. I know. And he's being sweet to Aaron and I like it. She's had two real weirdo boyfriends. Yeah.
我对皮特有点心动了。在这集里，我完全明白为什么他被评为我们本周的流行文化宝藏人物之一了。对，他是个小甜心，你忍不住会为他加油打气。我知道。而且他对艾琳很好，我很喜欢。她之前交过两个真正的怪胎男朋友。对。
So, I'm liking this. Well, that was Andy's ancestry. It was. Thank you so much, Steve Burgess, for all your good stuff. Angela's loving the call sheets. Loving them. And next week is Work Bus.
所以，我很喜欢这个发展。好吧，这就是安迪的祖先。确实是。非常感谢史蒂夫·伯吉斯（Steve Burgess）提供的所有精彩内容。安吉拉超级喜欢通告单。爱不释手。下周是“工作大巴”。
Get ready for those call sheets. Oh, boy. So you don't want to miss it. We'll see you next week. See you then. Have a good one. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf,
准备好迎接那些通告单吧。哦，天哪。所以你绝对不想错过。我们下周见。回头见。祝你们过得愉快。感谢收听“办公室女士”。《办公室女士》由Earwolf制作，
Jennifer and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our in-studio engineer is Sam Keeper. Our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
詹妮弗和安吉拉·金西。我们的资深制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的录音室工程师是萨姆·基珀。我们的剪辑和混音工程师是乔丹·达菲。我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布巴科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。